all right welcome to a brand-new week
it's Monday we had no press briefings on
Saturday and Sunday good news in the
sense that I wasn't going to be doing
them anyway I was taking the weekend off
but it just so happened that because I
guess because of Trump being very busy
tweeting tweeted 42 times on Easter and
I guess he was watching Easter videos
from churches and stuff like that anyway
we had no press conferences for the last
couple of days and indeed we are back
again it is a Monday we are about 17
minutes from the scheduled start of
today's press conference we have a crazy
situation here in Boston it's an insane
of rainstorm it's warm but it's very
rainy and windy and things are knocking
against my house there were a couple
booms earlier and we've been warned by
The Electric Company multiple times that
there may be power outages including
sustained power outages so if the stream
ends suddenly I wonder if the lights
would go off and that would transmit
before the stream shuts down I don't
know the order of what it would all be
but in any case I hope that I don't get
knocked off because we have really
really bad weather going on here okay
there is so much to discuss today if you
have questions for me and you're
watching on YouTube you can use the
super chat function your message will
show up in the lower left of the screen
if you're watching on twitch like Drent
rinoa who just signed up you can send a
message with your subscription it'll
show up in that vertical blue box at the
very very top we have a whole bunch of
new clips scheduled to publish today on
our YouTube channel including one that
went live 45 minutes ago about Donald
Trump's first signs that he may be
moving in the direction of firing doctor
foul Chi there is a poll on my Twitter
that you can vote in right now 20 to 20
100 people have voted so far does Trump
fire foul chi know yes in the next 48
hours yes in the next week yes in the
next month vote now twitter.com slash D
Pakman and we will keep an eye on that
that went up a little while ago so
that's available for folks who want to
participate
let's see okay let's get updated with
the latest numbers and of course welcome
if you're watching on Twitter twitch
YouTube and Facebook we have many things
happening the global coronavirus case
toll is at 1.9 million now I have three
studies for you momentarily about what
the real excuse me sorry for punching my
mic if you're wearing headphones that
probably hurt the real case number we
will get to that momentarily and we do
have about a hundred and nineteen
thousand deaths so far in the United
States the official number is five
hundred and eighty three thousand with
over 23,000 deaths at this point in time
you will see that yesterday we had 1500
new deaths which was actually a decline
if we want to look now at the curves we
seem to have been in a plateau since
about April second ish kind of staying
within this range we also are seeing the
daily new deaths we saw a plateau
starting about April 7 and then
yesterday we actually did have a decline
we'll see where today's numbers end up
but it seems that we are plateauing now
of course this is now going to make the
a scientific right-wing loons start to
say all of this all of this for so few
deaths now of course that ignores the
tragedy of the 60,000 deaths we are
likely to have but it's like an
anti-vaxxer who says measles is so rare
why do I need a vaccine well measles is
rare because of the success of the
vaccine that's the whole point in the
same way the numbers are starting to
turn around because of what we've been
doing and it would have turned around
much faster had we started doing things
at the beginning so these are the latest
numbers out of the United States the ih
Emmy model has just been updated I have
not yet looked at it okay let's see what
the latest update says according to this
the peak deaths is expected to be today
now they had previously said it was
April 10th adjust
today every day where we get data this
becomes more precise now officially
today it says that the death toll will
be between 464 and 7000 well no it won't
right I mean we've had 1,300 deaths so
far today so it's not gonna be 4 or 500
or 6 or 700 it's gonna be at least 1,300
and it's not going to be 7000 either
we'll see where we end up 1,500 1,600
1,700 we don't know and then in terms of
total deaths the number updated to
68,000 841 by August 4 importantly this
is just wave 1 future waves are not part
of this model let me take a look at my
home state of Massachusetts just for
kicks you can look at your state the
Massachusetts peak expected to not be
until April 29th despite the fact that
we're actually below where the curve
expected us to be but we'll see
expecting 8200 deaths in Massachusetts
now I have to admit this seems a little
weird because we currently have in
Massachusetts 844 deaths how are we
gonna get to it but listen I I hope it's
wrong obviously I hope we do better than
that but these are the latest these are
these are the latest updates expecting
today 882 deaths but we are at 88 yeah
see this is why some elements of this
model don't make sense to me the model
expects 882 deaths today in
Massachusetts and there's only three
hours left until we hit midnight GMT
which is when this resets and we're only
at 88 like it just it just doesn't seem
like that makes any sense am I missing
something maybe somebody can explain it
to me I don't know but anyway these are
the latest numbers and we will hope to
do better we are going to get today I'm
sure from Donald Trump a presentation on
this the wait hold on a second where is
it on this
the White House Counsel from hell to
reopen the economy I'm gonna get to that
in a little bit but first I want to get
to some of your super chats and and this
sort of thing I will mention that today
we have a patron target not a member
target and Ernesto is new patron number
one thanks Ernesto I'll make sure to
thank everybody and I'll say a little
bit more about that in a second let me
say thank you to wait a second I don't
want to miss anybody here Thunder speaks
has subscribed with twitch prime Breck
rrah
has subscribed with prime death Fox art
is a new twitch subscriber Chad Rath has
gifted a subscription GW Jumpman BDB has
signed up Skiz mage has subscribed
liquid ice subscribes and says
Wisconsinite here voting last week was
insane
panic Jia stick has cheered and the
mushroom man subscribes and says big fan
of the show have you ever read the
expanse series or watched the TV show I
have watched the TV show we've
interviewed the creators one of the
creators but I have not yet read the
books if you're joining me on youtube
remember to hit like and subscribe some
super chats coming in a Stephen Kenneth
Destiny bunnell the second says who's
better on policy Hillary Clinton or
Biden I'd say probably Biden captain
liability says what do you think of
Kennedy vs. Markey I think it's gonna be
an uphill battle for Kennedy but
anything can happen
Charlie says David your tweet correctly
points out if Hillary were POTUS and put
Chelsea on the council to reopen the
outrage on Fox would tear a hole in the
fabric of space-time Daniel Rivera says
what policies should Biden adopt for
leftist vote video coming up on that
tomorrow my friends Steven Kenneth
destiny bunnell the first says do you
agree with destiny that I don't know
that destiny said that so I'm not going
to react to things I don't know we're
actually said Dominic Richardson says
I'm a determinist have your views on
freewill changed my view on freewill is
it has not changed it has not changed my
view is that you can have on a technical
basis determinism in that we are all
operating within a certain physiologic
physiological structure but still
effectively have freewill I think
there's actually a name for that sort of
blending of free will and determinism I
forget the name of that blending but I'm
sure someone is going to remind me vad
är says david pakman Germany branch
oh no VAD are signs up on youtube david
pakman Germany branch office
headquarters says hey can Trump really
afford to fire foul gee I wish the
answer was no but I fear the answer is
yes Tour mode Kasbah sends a 19
Norwegian kroner super chap and mr.
lieutenant pink says I think Pedro from
Colombia should take over no its CEO
ello the country Columbia not Colombia
like South Carolina compatibilism
compatibilism was the word that uh that
I was looking for there let me say thank
you to yes Jenny kantorovich or canter
avec who is patron number two and Evan
and Irene are a patrons number three
today patron number three I guess more
properly said okay this is today we are
expecting a big announcement about the
Trump coronavirus counsel from hell okay
now I want to remind you guys about a
few things first of all we've got Ivanka
as I say and by the way this thread is
on my Twitter page please retweet it
Ivanka is merely Trump's daughter and
has no business being on any counsel if
it were Hillary Clinton doing the same
with Chelsea it would be 24/7 outrage on
Fox News we then have Jared Kushner this
was Jeff Kushner cramming 60 seconds
over the BS what the president asked is
that all of the recommendations that we
made be based on data he wanted us to be
very rigorous to make sure that we were
studying the data collecting data a lot
of things
this country were happening very quickly
and we want to make sure that we were
trying to keep updating our models and
making sure that we were making informed
decisions and informed recommendations
to him based on the data that we were
able to collect and put together yeah so
he goes on for 60 seconds without
actually saying anything
he also oh you know what I have to find
the thread because these are not in the
right order I apologize for that okay we
have Wilbur Ross on the council Wilbur
Ross said coronavirus would be good for
the economy I don't want to talk about a
victory lap over a very unfortunate very
malignant disease but the fact is it
does give businesses yet another thing
to consider when they go through their
review of their supply chain and top of
all the other things because that you
had SARS you have the African swine
virus there now you have this it's
another risk factor that people need to
take into account so I think it will
help to accelerate the return of jobs to
North America some to us probably some
to Mexico as I wanted so there's Wilbur
Ross then also on the council is Jared
Kushner who said they are our
ventilators not the states and if in
instances where in cities they're
running out but the state still has a
stockpile and the notion of the federal
stockpile was it supposed to be our
stockpile it's not supposed to be state
stockpiles that they then use so we're
encouraging the states to make sure that
they're assessing the needs they're
getting the data from their local local
situations and then trying to fill it
with the supplies that we've given them
okay and then of course also Larry
Kudlow who seemed visibly drunk during
multiple recent appearances I'm not
gonna play this one right now it's a
longer clip but he said that in many
ways America should stay at work this is
before the logarithmic increase of cases
in the United States so this is the
council to reopen America as well as
mark meadows Stephen minuchin and Robert
light Iser I would expect that a big
focus of today's press briefing is going
to be about this Donald Trump probably
will brag and cheer about this as if
it's some big accomplishment despite the
fact that it is riddled with people who
are in completely over their heads
and completely unqualified to be on this
council whatsoever they were actually
part people who were part of the problem
are going to be are being rewarded and
are being placed on this council which
is crazy okay let's see here I'm gonna
try to pull up another video where maybe
we can be we can see what's going on in
the room for the press briefing so we
can keep an eye on what's going on yeah
here we go I've got another looks like
Fox News is very very much in the room
and we will keep an eye on the press
briefing expected to start in just a few
minutes and people starting to file into
the room so there is that welcome
friends if you're just joining me on
Twitter twitch YouTube or Facebook it we
are back I was away for a couple of days
there were no press briefing away I mean
I was just in a different room of my
house and we are now we are now back a
few super chats who are coming in Matt
Chavez says do you think do you think we
can get Bernie bros behind this idea or
not back biden remove Trump and then
remove Biden behind the T of the 25th
amendment or pressure him to resign I I
think that that's crazy
and Bernie endorsed Abidin today and
we'll have extensive coverage of that
tomorrow
artim Maz Vidale says why is the
progressive voice your biggest hater I
don't I have no idea I don't even know
what you mean Stephen Kenneth destiny
bunnell the first says David this is it
I will no longer be sending super chats
you don't take the bite on dumb question
so that's it okay
Matthias Noren signs up Jesus was a
communists as France extending lockdown
to the 15th of May closing borders till
the start of September this isn't going
to end for a while stay safe David not
surprising and a retro path acts as is
the wind upsetting in Boston well it's
not upsetting I just don't want to have
a power outage and and that that may
well happen okay um let me see here
gonna pull up a couple of other things
to be fully prepared today for the live
stream as we wait on the start of this
yet another press briefing during which
I would expect a lot of bragging and a
big introduction of the completely
deranged task force to open America the
council to reopen America on which
Trump's daughter and son-in-law are
going to be sitting that's coming up
very very soon let me say thank you to
Edward Patel who is new patron number
four today
and Shane Collier who is new patron
number five okay let me do this real
quick so as many of you know we often
have like a new member goal during these
streams and many people will generously
get a membership on my website last week
a few viewers had an idea they said
David they didn't come to me and say sir
nobody talks to me that way I'm not
delusional like that but they said David
um you should do a patreon goal during
your stream because a lot of people have
patreon already and it's just something
different it'll be exciting it'll be
beautiful
so I'm trying that today okay here's the
bottom line
these streams are part of what is
keeping us even during the coronavirus
fiasco there's a lot of people hundreds
and hundreds who have had to cancel
their support to our show because
they're feeling it much the way that a
lot of people are feeling it so we had
389 people stop support in March we've
had close to a hundred in April so far
and I get it I don't have a grudge
against any one of those people I
appreciate that they were able to
support me for the time that they were
now my ask to you is if you were not
down to your last dollar or to consider
making a pledge of as little as a dollar
a month on patreon you can pledge as
much as you want but it can be just a
dollar
I will thank everybody it's patreon.com
slash david pakman show it's really
really quick last time we did this we
had a bunch of people who said I wanted
to do it but I didn't have a patreon
account at the time I missed you saying
my name well we are here and I'm going
to say everyone's name
so patreon.com slash a David Pakman show
is the spot we had five people already
do it and again I
think everybody's in the same boat I
think eventually it could be much longer
than Donald Trump thinks the economy is
going to come back everybody's going to
be fine all of that stuff but in the
meantime we are doing a patreon pledge
drive today and my my commitment was
we're not cutting ours we're not doing
layoffs we're not doing any of that
stuff
everybody's working from home we've done
what needs to happen to keep everybody
safe and the streams and the support is
what has been essentially keeping us
level so I appreciate that okay let's
get to some new reporting or data about
what might be the real level of
infection with coronavirus we know that
the official number right five hundred
and eighty three thousand in the United
States or 1.9 million globally that's
not the real number because a lot of
people aren't getting tested there are
asymptomatic cases where numb people
don't even know that they're sick etc
etc one study from Germany tested a
bunch of people in gang gilt and they
found that there was a 14% antibody rate
14 percent now there's a couple
different question marks has 14% of the
German population really had the virus I
don't think so
one possibility is that the antibodies
are not being correctly distinguished
between SARS CoV - meaning this corona
virus and other corona viruses but one
data point is that 14 percent of the
people in gang gilt had antibodies we
have another study from Austria which
found that the level of infection early
in April was somewhere between where are
the exact numbers somewhere between
point one two and point seven six
percent that would be a rate that is
roughly equal to the numbers in Austria
Austria officially right now having how
many cases was it about 14,000 or
potentially it could be up to a few
times the official rate that's another
data point and then we have a sewage
test from here in Massachusetts
there was a sewage test wastewater test
done in an area with five
cases and what this study found was that
there were somewhere between where was
that number between 2300 and 115,000
infected people this is also a study
with a lot of question marks around it
this would imply that the real rate is
anywhere from five to two hundred and
fifty times the official rate do I think
that the real rate is 250 X no that
would mean that about 140 million people
have had corona virus in the United
States I don't think that that's the
reality do I think that the real rate
could be 5x or 10x it's possible it's
certainly possible and I think what
we're learning from these studies study
after study is that we really don't know
what the actual rate is because the data
is varying significantly around the
world and in addition to that we are
seeing a we are seeing different
infection rates different death rates
there's just a lot we don't yet know
that my guess is we will find out more
about in the period between wave one and
wave 2 that that's my my hypothesis let
me say thank you to aunty who is new
patron number six today Alec Foy is new
patron number seven at patreon.com slash
david pakman show paul christian hagen
is new patron number eight today Matthew
Farley is new patron number nine Michael
Yuen is new patron number ten today and
Eric Sandin is new patron number eleven
thanks very much I really appreciate
that want to say thanks over on twitch
to swoosh 90 who has subscribed as well
as Wade Carroll
Edgar V Calderon and bolo 510 have all
subscribed also big thank you to / - Rob
0:08
and Dems Errol cool sling blade Jimmy
ten pins as well very much appreciate
all of that support okay other super
chats that I want to get to Okoye Madrid
says I'm so tired of hearing from Trump
let the experts speak he is delusional
well my guess is here some of the people
you will soon be hearing from from
Trump's new counsel not experts in
fighting infectious disease sadly that's
for sure
what wrong window there zesty African
says why is the media treating Biden so
differently than Cavanaugh well the
circumstances are very very different
Jeremie comfort whoops where'd that go
Jeremy comfort says get me out of the
simulation you and me both millennial
cooking coroner says where do I find
your full show depends where you are
subscribed but if you're a subscriber on
a patreon we post those every day if
you're a subscriber on the website same
thing you go you just log in and then
you click on member content and then
whoops that's where you will see that
see Willie says lost a super chat
donation and gained another new listener
and I love the content Thanks tormund
Kasbah sends a super chat Jared Johnson
says could you please explain to your
audience the difference between Trump's
separation policy and what the Obama
administration did with undocumented
minors have done it many times and not
the topic of today's stream but check
out my numerous archived videos about
that
thanks to VA Dr Jacob Ratner says friend
thinks once lockdown is over crime will
spike what are your thoughts well crime
is down during the lock downs it's not
crazy to imagine that it might go back
to the level that previously had
although we don't fully know looks like
a few folks are getting up and maybe
leaving so maybe we're still a little
bit of a ways from the start here let me
say thank you to Ryan frost ad or frost
ad who is new patron number 12 today at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
thanks Ryan Jamal Swift says hey homie
do you think tapper should have just let
it go for the greater good especially
knowing how sensitive Trump is of
criticism nope Jake Tapper was
a journalist and he was asking real
questions - Anthony foul tree and that's
what Jake Tapper should be doing Donna
Williams says do you think Trump has
dementia thanks for all you do I think
Trump has clearly declined cognitively
it would be outside my area of expertise
to say whether it is or is not dementia
and I would defer to you know folks like
dr. John Gartner bandy Lee Justin Frank
and other mental health experts on that
issue Heidi says keep up the good work
thanks Heidi maxi taxi says hey David I
was a trump supporter until I found you
on the Joe Rogan podcast and now I've
completely changed my politics thanks to
you and how logical you think thank you
well thank you very much appreciate that
drew goose says chess tournaments for
patrons that would make me join you know
I think if we did a patron only chess
tournament I don't know that we would
get that many people because only like a
slice of the people that support us on
patreon play chess so I don't know I
don't know if we've got the numbers for
that Stephen Kenneth destiny bunnell de
frst says thoughts under the Daily wires
Michael note Noel's he wants I don't
know what he wants
I've not you know last time I saw a clip
of him was over a year ago don't know
anything about him Daniel Rivera says
what are your opinions on Mexican food I
am acutely and aggressively in favor
very much in favor of of Mexican food
wasp says preliminary serological data
from Denmark indicates that for each
tested case there could be 40 to 70
unknown cases that's insane and I've not
seen that study and I would be I would
be glad to check it out
BYOB b-12
says you should talk about the
Republicans and Trump for canceling
Easter always complain about the
Democrats canceling Christmas Easter way
more holy I just don't even care about
the the that I mean it's you know yes I
understand what you're saying there's
hypocrisy but these are not people who
care about hypocrisy if you're just
joining me the press conference is was
scheduled to start at 5:00 p.m.
I'm receiving bulletins that it has been
pushed to 5:30 p.m. Eastern Time that's
in 20 minutes in the meantime we will be
here taking questions reading your
comments and the like if you're joining
me on YouTube please do me the favor of
hitting like and subscribe like and
subscribe both very helpful to me a
couple of new patrons that I want to
thank John Erickson is new patron number
13 today Dylan Littlefield is new patron
number 14 and Carl Huff t'en is new
patron number 15 today thanks very much
guys we have this goal of 50 I don't
know if we can make it I don't know if
we can make it but I very much
appreciate the 15 folks who have pledged
so far one of the big advantages of
patreon over memberships is that the
membership start at two bucks a month
patreon starts at $1 a month which we
want to break down all barriers all
barriers should be broken down strongly
ok stand up and fight back sends a super
chat Andre Anaya says considering the
fire foul cheat we'd do you think dr.
Burks has been praising Trump as a
safety measure yes he has zero tolerance
for criticism but will sometimes do the
right thing if he can claim credit
absolutely what is this Wow I don't know
what they are playing there but that
looks weird
Alex Walker says Mexican food is racist
saij but Bowen says love the show could
you comment on Tara Reid's accusations I
have trouble putting them aside have
already commented on it stabby 666 says
why broadcast this line more on every
day you're spreading his ignorance I'm
giving him pre publicity so we attempt
to live fact check these which is what I
think corporate media should do
pretending they're not happening isn't a
good idea
because people are watching them on
place
is where the there is no fact-checking
so I've calculated that the most good I
can do is by making every attempt to
live fact-check let me say thank you to
Matt bond Matt bondas new patron number
16 today at patreon.com slash david
pakman show Emanuel Ramirez Vera says
what day and time do you take calls
typically we take calls Wednesdays at
12:15 p.m. Eastern Time
typically and we always announce it on
Twitter Chris K says I now know someone
that has died from kovat 19 it's too
real now many many of us do more and
more people know someone who has died
from kovat 19 and as much as that seems
to be making some people take it more
seriously it's also disappointing that
oftentimes people don't take it
seriously until it affects them
personally gay marriage for example you
know you see Republican elected
officials who for years and years
campaign against gay marriage then they
have you know LGBTQ family member and
they changed their mind it's great that
they eventually came to the right view
but it'd be better if it didn't take
personal contact to be able to empathize
with others and understand the
importance of supporting LGBT rights oh
really
Thank You Vicki Owens has grabbed a
youtube subscription thanks Vicki Cisco
has grabbed a youtube subscription klaus
gray blur says south africa has millions
living in squatter camps we are going to
experience an apocalypse do you agree
yeah I mean I think that in there are
all sorts of different areas where there
will be continued problems homeless
shelters certainly refugee camps in
different places it's going to be very
very complicated for a long time Gabriel
Garcia says have you ever visited
Scandinavia yes and I loved it I've been
to
okay now I have to remember hold on
Scandinavia that include is is is
Finland part of Scandinavia or not I
always remember I make a mistake I've
been to Denmark Denmark is Scandinavia
I've been to Finland but is Finland not
Scandinavia are not Nordic I know that
there's some there's some terminology
there Finland is not some people are
saying it is okay you know what here's
the deal I've been to Estonia Denmark
and Finland loved all of them loved all
of them
John Kurokawa says if Trump fires foul
chief out you will hopefully go on a
cable news tour and expose him to the
public especially those who still
believe Trump's lies that may be the one
very small upside of Anthony Falchi
getting fired but I think we're better
off with him staying let me say thank
you to Stephanie Siskind stephanie is
new patron number 17 today at
patreon.com slash david pakman show also
Ryan B is new patron number 18 today at
patreon.com slash david pakman show if
you're just joining us we we are not
doing a membership drive today we are
doing a patreon drive because it starts
cheaper and I don't want to keep anybody
out for financial reasons
so I'm thanking folks signing up at
patreon.com slash david pakman show if
you're just joining us it is it seems as
though the press briefing has been
delayed to 5:30 p.m. Eastern Time we are
expecting a lot of bragging from Donald
Trump because it does seem as though the
US case and death numbers may have
peaked and are starting to decline a
little bit we are also expecting a heavy
focus on Donald Trump announcing the
council to reopen America of the seven
people on it too or his own relatives
make of that what you will but expecting
a big big focus on that today okay Tour
mode Kasbah sends a super chat max says
if we believe Tara Reid victims of
sexual assault are forced to choose
between two sexual predators for
president and voting is like consenting
that well if you believe in harm
reduction
you vote for the person with the best
policies and it's clear to me who that
is and I'll have more about that
tomorrow
I'm with Bernie and Noam Chomsky on this
they say you you've got a vote for Joe
Biden
that's what Bernie is saying and that's
what Noam Chomsky is saying and and I'm
with them
Ashley Pearson says president Trump
constantly being late to his own press
conferences really highlights how little
respect he has for the American people
yeah he doesn't really respect anyone
Stephen Kenneth Destin even else's
thoughts on the bench to Piro jenk ugar
debate didn't see it Nanette burrows and
Jian song have grabbed YouTube
subscriptions our southern nest
Adventure says thanks for keeping them
honest horrible president and
administration thank you I very much
appreciate that and we're we're doing
what we can and you know no matter what
happens in November we will continue
keeping an eye on everybody to the
extent that we can let me say thank you
to not yell 34 for the twist Prime
subscription over at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman Matt bond says confirmed
Trump's friend who had or died Kova dove
died of kovat yet Trump's mentioned that
friend of his his obese friend who had
kovat I haven't heard Trump say that the
guy died of kovat but I don't know that
anyone has been able to confirm that
that person actually exists
Lars Ave Larson says when will reporters
start demanding Trump answer questions
instead of doing self-glorification you
know I've talked about that before the
obvious thing would be keep asking Trump
the same question every reporter until
he answers the problem in a practical
sense is that when you call Trump out on
one lie
he tells three other lies and it's like
a virally growing it's like a branching
a set of lies and I just you know he'll
just tell more lies and then which lie
do you ask asked about it's a really
tough situation I used to always say
just keep asking the same question over
and over again until I read a couple of
pieces that say it might sound like that
would work but it wouldn't really work
in a lot of ways it would not actually
accomplish much at all and the trumpets
would just say he's being badgered
either way it's not like they would say
wow he's not answering the question they
would say wow these reporters are
terrible people so I don't know what the
solution is to that issue let me say
thank you to Elmer Haney Elmer Haney is
new patron number 19 today and Robert
wheeler is new patron number 20 today
thanks Elmer and Robert very much
appreciate your support today Danny
Thompson says when an antibody test is
here it will be because it was built on
the viral loads of gay men with HIV
food-for-thought who are still against
gay rights marriage looking at you Mike
Pence I didn't know that antibody tests
that that's how antibody tests work that
I hadn't read that but I'm interested in
learning more
Daniel Rivera says what must we do to
get a Pakman haircut stream I don't know
I mean listen I think if we got to I
think if we got to if we got to 4,000
patrons I would do a live haircut on
stream i think i think that is safe for
me to say let me say thank you to jolie
Grace who is new patron number 21 today
at patreon.com slash david pakman show
pedro me Ramon says firing foul Chee
would be idiotic of course we are
dealing with drum and his asinine and
toxic way of handling things he's going
to get us all killed
Waller is me says here's some bailout
money for you as much as I hate teaching
math online I am lucky to still have a
job in a regular paycheck next I need to
buy some stamps support the postal
service you know a lot of people don't
know this and it's probably it's it's a
bigger story but one of the reasons that
the postal service on paper is so
financially upside-down
that there is a requirement on the
Postal Service to free to pre-fund
retirement benefits decades ahead of
time no big business would ever be
expected to do that and with many big
businesses if you said you need to now
pay for the future
pensions of people a whole bunch of
private businesses would be totally not
viable on paper that's an element and
Thom Hartmann has a lot of coverage of
this that's part of why it's so easy to
say the post office isn't viable as an
organization because there's
requirements on the Postal Service that
are not placed on any other business or
almost any other business it's it's
truly crazy and I encourage you to
google that you can find out a lot about
that Adrienne benningfield says go for
long hair David yeah I mean I I don't
know I could because I could be you'd
have to force me to cut my hair on
stream but I think if we got to 4,000
patrons I would be willing to do it I'm
probably only we actually see here it's
conceivable that it how it's possible in
10 days I could actually have a man
button it's possible I'm trying to see
if I squeeze back there's I mean there's
like a handful of something back there I
think if I can go another 10 days it's
it's conceivable that I could have a man
bun which i think would be a total game
changer for the show I mean a
progressive talk show hosted by someone
with a man bun I don't know that's I
don't even know if the show would
survive quite frankly but yeah for now
it's just gonna keep growing let me say
thank you to Deb Farrell Deb is new
patron number 22 today Jonathan Blum is
new paid patron number 23
tom is new patron number 24 today Brian
gross is new patron number 25 and
Dominic Martineau is new patron number
26 thanks very much guys I really do
appreciate that support and I guess
maybe some people are interested in
in a live on stream haircut okay we are
apparently eight minutes from the now
rescheduled Trump press briefing we are
expecting bragging lying and talking
about the reopen the economy Council
which was announced today full rocker
says will threats against foul Chi rise
now yes and doctor foul she already
needs armed security and he will need it
even more after Donald Trump started
targeting him on Twitter Matt bond says
it's been confirmed Trump's friend was a
New York real estate mogul named Stanley
Chara okay that's news to me I was not
up to speed on that John good friend
says David are you concerned there's not
enough pushback Maggitt messaging from
Biden and the Dems to Trump's disastrous
response to this pandemic yes I am
indeed I am indeed concerned about that
lisa kline wart says weekly pitch in to
thank you for doing this you really do
help make these almost daily briefings
thanks Lisa
and Eric Lamont says Trump firing foul
tree nail in the reelection coffin I
would never say anything is the nail in
Trump's re-election coffin because it
has weave that's been suspected many
times and it has never actually worked
it's never been that thing where now
Trump clearly can't win and you know I
think that it's going to come down to
the economy in November and what's going
on with the virus in November ultimately
I think that's that's what it will come
down to Chris K says 4,000 patrons for a
cut
how many patrons from that are you I
don't know the answer to that let me say
let's take a look together I don't look
at the patreon page often where are we
right now
well we're far so we're only at 17 51
patrons so we're about half way to 4,000
and that listen I don't know that I
would have to be forced I would have to
be my arm would have to be pulled into
cutting my hair myself live during a
stream so that's why I'm saying for
and it would be it would be quite a show
that's for sure let me say thanks to
Drake Stone who is new patron number 27
today
Fintan Hennessey is new patron number 28
Andrew Miller is new patron number 29
and brian de leus is a $50 a month
patron and is patron number 30 today
thanks to all of you and to brian for
the very very generous a pledge at
patreon.com slash david pakman show
Eileen are dword says man-bun yes I
would love all elements of that I mean
listen the way things are going it this
is going in one of two directions either
I'm cutting my hair live on stream or
I'm going to end up having a ponytail in
about 10 days
Dominic Richardson oh sorry no Jared
Johnson says I did the math and had
Warren dropped out prior to Super
Tuesday it would have helped Biden it's
annoying people won't do the math love
your work
Dominic Richard says Richardson says
will people in one to two hundred years
view the way we treat animals similarly
to the view we treat the way we view
slavery today I don't pretend to know
humans are notoriously bad at those
types of predictions and anybody
claiming to know the answer to that
question 200 years out we just don't
know we just don't know
Ali Mack says do you think the
journalists should push questions and
challenge Trump more rather than let him
ramble I addressed that about 10-15
minutes ago so I'm not gonna do it over
again right now living life with Lisa
says I'm proud that number 45 finally
admitted that he is a presidential
disaster lol I'm guessing that's related
to his tweet about presidential disaster
zones or declarations or something like
that
Zach Bushman says David do you think the
u.s. is weak public transit
infrastructure has reduced kovat spread
no coincidence that NYC is so hard hit
with this in mind that's an interesting
that's an interesting idea
I've not thought about that too deeply
but that may be a
factor that may be a factor looks like
they're starting to be more activity in
the press briefing room
Andrea Hughes is new patron number 31
today and Henrik Steen is new patron
number 32 today Andrea and Henrik thank
you so much we are two-thirds of the way
to our goal of 50 and remember if you
are just joining on YouTube please do
hit that like button and the subscribe
button had another great call with my
YouTube rep I have a fantastic youtube
rep and he said your streams are doing a
lot for your channel and they do much
better when people are liking and
subscribing off of the stream because it
signals to YouTube hey recommend this
stream with the guy in the corner
rather than that stream or this other
stream so always very much appreciate
the the likes and subscribes portholes
says why do 30 percent of Americans
think coronavirus was made in a lab I've
not seen that study but it wouldn't
surprise me there is a lot of weaponized
stupidity in this country Tour mode
Kasbah sends a super chat Mia Max sends
a super chat Brian gross says will Trump
fire foul Qi that's actually my question
to you you can go to twitter.com slash D
Pakman and vote in my poll does Trump
fire foul Qi as of right now we have
2300 votes
30% believe the answer is no the other
70 believe the answer is some version of
yes with disagreement over when it will
happen a plurality say it will be in the
next week 20% say in the next 48 hours
19% say in the next month so you can
vote on that twitter.com slash D Pakman
let me say a huge thank you to Christian
Boger Christian Boger has just made a
pledge of $100 a month at patreon.com
slash david pakman show
and his new patron number 33 of 50 today
Christian I can't thank you enough for
that incredibly incredibly generous
patreon pledge really do appreciate that
Chris K says bingo today I'm not gonna
play today there's just so much going on
and we've got it's been a couple days
since the last briefing
I'm not playing bingo today but people
can feel free to of course a rich ropa
thak says thoughts on the weirdest
Wrestlemania of all time I have never
watched professional wrestling other
than when I was four in Argentina and we
had our we had Argentinian professional
wrestling since then I've never watched
professional wrestling so I couldn't
tell you anything about it Ricky
Williams says thoughts on the argument
of government and private healthcare
both working while we watch what is gone
with the US Postal Service health care
both working I don't know that I
understand the question and I apologize
for that black wave says Pham tailed
that okay boomergirl that she can get it
jus heard like dead ass she has some odd
waifu vibes vibes
oh ah wow that actually sounds like a
viewer who went by the name a gr
previously but today under a different
under a different name weird thanks to
Jennifer Daly for signing up at a Leo
Divino as well as Zoey Ferguson sends
super chats Zoey says what are your
thoughts on the new reopening America
panel that involves Ivanka and Jared
yeah earlier in the stream I played a
bunch of clips for people including
clips of Wilbur Ross who's on the panel
Jared Kushner who's on the panel a drunk
Larry Kudlow who's on the panel I think
it's an abomination I think it's a
complete and total abomination and I
will have full fuller coverage of it
tomorrow I played a couple of clips
today but I'm gonna dig into the panel
the council much more tomorrow I expect
Trump to talk a lot about that today
imagine if all of them file into the
room when the door opens momentarily I
hope that doesn't happen
both for social distancing purposes and
for sanity purposes but it's certainly
possible that it will tour Mode casbah
says a lot of doctors say they are told
to say the cause of death should be
kovat even if they suspect otherwise
what are your thoughts that's been
mostly conspiracies as far as I've seen
and we've talked about doctor foul she
has talked about the determination about
whether someone died from Kovac or with
Kovac I I'm not even gonna get into it
in more detail I've already talked about
it and it's not there's a lot of
conspiratorial thinking that is being
generated by it and that's a very very
bad thing dr. Terry White says I really
appreciate your balanced analyses thanks
doctor appreciate it
maxi taxi says did you notice that the
same people making the kovat vaccine
were shorting stocks on international
travel airlines before word of the
travel ban weird stock transforming I
did not see that I did not see that and
I have not independently confirmed that
that is true Jeff Karl signs up at the
soy boy level Neil Irving says can you
imagine him blasting him as Tiny tony
Fowey maybe nothing is beyond
imagination with this president be
Chambers White has subscribed on YouTube
unknown prodigy says do you think Trump
really would fire pouchy
I believe that Trump absolutely would I
don't know if Trump will make of it what
you will we are getting dangerously
close to the start of today's press
briefing I want to welcome everybody
who's watching on Twitter Facebook
twitch and YouTube we have no membership
goal today we have only a patreon goal
you can pledge as little as one single
solitary dollar at patreon.com slash
david pakman show I made a commitment
that we are not cutting staff for any of
our employees we are not what we're
basically trying to ride this through
and keep everything level and one of the
great sort of
balancing factors in that has been the
support that comes in during these
streams so consider yourself politely
invited to make a pledge of as little as
a dollar at patreon.com slash david
pakman show can go as high as you want
we got a hundred dollar pledge today but
a dollar a month really makes a
difference and I have agreed to cut my
hair on stream if we get to four
thousand although I imagine that that is
not going to happen anytime soon it's
certainly what we would call a stretch
goal as the kids say these days
Jean moleish says you are amazing thanks
John
gnorga PAB says have you ever been to
Montevideo Uruguay what is your opinion
I have been there I have been there I've
also been to Colonia
Oh to Hawaii and I loved it I mean it's
familiar I'm from Argentina Uruguay is
familiar in many ways if one is
Argentinean although the culture is
different part of it is that the accent
in Hawaii is very similar to that in
Buenos is where I was born and there's
this fantastic I guess it wouldn't be
called sort of like a Central Market in
Monday video which is the capital of who
do I wear clothes that you're okay
getting completely covered in barbecue
smoke smell when you go but absolutely
delightful place and Colonia is
interesting as well I took a boat from
Buenos Aires to Colonia then took a bus
from Colonia to Montevideo and then took
the boat back directly from Monday video
to Buenos itis and I don't like boats I
tend to get seasick and the last 15
minutes of the ride from Buena siteís to
Colonia were not pretty
it was not pretty even with my Dramamine
it was uh it was pretty ugly let me say
thank you to Amy for doubling her
patreon pledge from five to ten dollars
a month Amy I'm calling that pledge
number 34 I know that you're not
strictly speaking a new patron but I'm
still calling it 34 and I want to say
thanks to Scott Gala
add who is new patron number 35 today at
patreon.com slash david pakman show we
are getting close to today's press
briefing should start momentarily
Zoe Ferguson says thanks for the answer
my pleasure
Claudio Batista says keep it up Ana
Burgos says will Trump blow a gasket
with Cuomo taking initiative leading
governor's to reopen the economy I think
Trump probably just won't talk about it
that's my instinct yeah Andrew Cuomo
with some surrounding governor's are
starting to come up with a plan for
phase 2 reopening of the economy it's
not clear exactly when they're going to
start but you know Trump Trump doesn't
like being what's the word
this isn't like being upstaged some
would call it cucked but that would be
inappropriate upstaged I think is a more
couth way of saying it okay Ricky
Williams says news that Trump is
refusing to bailout the post office
assume conservatives wanted privacy
ivett eyes and to fail kind of shows
what can happen keeping private
insurance around if not done right
iridescent ink do you find it ironic
that Trump calls himself a stable genius
despite being outwitted by a piece of
RNA 30,000 lines long without a brain
and not alive yeah I actually played
today let me see if I can find it this
may be the most embarrassing video of
Trump that I've ever seen and I know
that different people will disagree on
that
where was this video here it is check
this out look at how incompetent
Trump is it's absolutely stunning this
was from Friday brilliant enemy they
develop drugs like the antibiotics you
see it antibiotics used to solve every
problem now one of the biggest problems
the world has is the germ has gotten so
brilliant that the antibiotic can't keep
up with it right and they're constantly
trying to come up with a new people go
to a hospital and they catch they go for
a hot upper
and that's no problem but they end up
dying from from problems you know the
problems I'm talking about there's a
whole genius to it
we're fighting not only is it hidden but
it's very smart right
it's the the Germans figured out a way
for antibiotics not to affect it of
course that is the case with viruses
rather than bacteria
Jonathan pitcher sends a super chap a
rich ropa thak says Pablo Merkin should
move from Torquato de tella don't know a
thing about it
Ashley backer signs up on YouTube Mac
says hey David my point about Tara Reid
was about how the situation feels
especially for victims of sexual assault
not don't vote for Joe got it got it got
it got it Zachary Foster says you see
the my Koster home interview on MSNBC
where he said the overarching narrative
should be now be should now be who goes
back to work events in reopened economy
I did not see that I did not see that
the Beckman Nader says David who do you
think will be the next big leader for
the left now that bernie is out and has
endorsed by didn't I'm thinking AOC and
not really anyone else I think that it
may be a 40-ish I think it might be a
Democrat in their 40s who is on the more
progressive side but not the ultra
progressive that may emerge is the
leader I don't know who it would be but
I think it would be someone who is not
already thought of as an up-and-coming
elected official but someone who's been
right in there close to the left edge
but not the most left that will take one
or two progressive issues and really
push them that's my sense but I don't
know okay let me say thank you to let me
say thank you to carry Shaw Kerry has
just doubled her patreon pledge so we're
gonna call Kerry patron number 36
Jason Kaiser has more than doubled his
pledge so he becomes number 37
lisa-marie Walter is new patron number
38 today and pear Alexson paired Alexson
is new patron number 39 today thanks so
much very much appreciate everybody
support we're not doing memberships
today we're just keeping it much simpler
and doing patreon.com slash david pakman
show as we await the start of today's
press briefing
Dominic Richardson says thoughts on
global unification if you're talking
about one-world government I mean I
don't I I just don't I don't see it if
you mean if you mean unifying behind the
BI against the virus for example or
against climate change then of course I
would love to see it I think nationalist
strategies fail us hugely brutally
against a lot of what we're fighting
right now tormak as Bo says what do you
consider truthful info which media it's
not about which media it's about going
to primary sources go I go to primary
sources and understanding when something
is satire or deliberate fake news
there's someone I went to high school
with who I had to unfollow on Facebook
because she's constantly posting stuff
from literal fake news websites like you
go to the about and it says this is like
for entertainment only this is not real
news and she's posting it it's toxic so
you've got to critically analyze primary
sources and seek corroboration you know
for me to give you a list of media
outlets would be well I I wouldn't
possibly do that
Christopher Panetta says you know in the
old world people would sacrifice their
leader to the land when famine or
flutter sickness went around too long
just saying there's something to think
about Ryan a barbed and ZEB Brown sends
super chats zoe Ferguson grabs a youtube
subscription let me say thank you to
Mason Pramod who is new patron number 40
today and Eric with a k' who is new
patron
number 41 today at patreon.com slash
david pakman show very much appreciate
that
Jake Feldman says thank you for your
devotion to facts thanks Jake for
appreciating that unknown prodigy says
if Trump learned something no matter how
simple Trump assumes no one knows this
fact and he must teach it to us all
literally like a little kid yeah
very often Trump will say you know a lot
of people didn't know X or Y and what
Trump means by that is he learned at
five minutes ago he learned at five
minutes before the camera turned on
other people of course know it that's
essentially what Trump means for people
wondering how you get a message up on
the bottom of the screen there those are
YouTube super chats I do want to say
thanks over on twitch to coral who has
subscribed with twitch prime also want
to say thanks to all of T DS who has
subscribed at tier 1 at twitch.tv slash
David Pakman really appreciate people
who watch on twitch we've been working
very strongly at growing our following
on twitch we've got about about 33
thousand followers on twitch which is
great given that we just launched on
twitch nine months ago we've not have
even been on twitch for a year and so
far so good and very very strongly
appreciate being on there other super
shots coming in Mary Allen says dialogue
with the trumpets today was fascinating
they kept referring to outdated
information as lies not understanding
how things evolve as data is gathered am
I missing something no that's a really
common rumpus move which is they'll say
well a person Y said Z six months ago
and that ended up not being true
therefore you can trust Trump and nobody
else but things change we learn more
projections change data facts science
the scientific method critical thinking
it's not even worth it
III wouldn't even bother quite frankly
Mary the Beckman ater says it sounds
like you're describing ROA Khanna who if
I remember correctly was a Bernie
campaign senior advisor not sure if that
would work but I'd be open to that as
well
Rokon is an interesting candidate to be
a powerful force in the future of the
progressive movement I think that's
interesting joe jay says how can we
fight conspiracy theories they've gotten
so intense since the virus started have
you seen how bad Bill Gates is getting
it so scary yeah I've had to I've had to
mute a bunch of people on Twitter and
unfollow a bunch of personal friends
like acquaintances people from high
school not people I hang out with let me
be clear on Facebook because they are
also posting the Bill Gates conspiracy
theories it's it's sick it's sick let me
say thank you to Annalise Sund
who is new patron number 42 today and
Jim Scully
Jim Scully is new patron number 43 today
thank you so much as some of you know
because of the virus we had close to 400
people stop their financial support of
our show last month and about a hundred
more this month and I get it I mean the
way I see it we're all in this together
we really are but if you are in a
position where you can financially
support the work that we do consider
making a pledge of $1 a month at
patreon.com slash david pakman show or
more we had $100 a month pledge today
and a $50 a month pledge today but it's
it's all equally appreciated it's just
about numbers and I think currently we
have where are we we are at 1763 patrons
right now at patreon.com slash david
pakman show consider making a pledge and
we can fill this bar up Bigley
very very big Lee any moment now we are
expecting the start of today's press
briefing we are 46 minutes late right
now originally scheduled for 5:00 p.m.
Eastern Time then it was apparently
rescheduled for 5:30 p.m. Eastern Time
and it is now 16 minutes past that so we
don't know what's going on but it does
look as though the room is now full and
any moment now
we should be expecting people to walk in
the door would be my guess unless
something is very very wrong
Kaleo Divino says what is Taleo say do
you believe that Trump's Council to
reopen America will make the situation
with the virus much worse there's a very
good chance of that yeah I mean you know
look at the people that are on it right
these people are going to reopen America
two sevenths of this is Trump's family
it's sick it's sick these people are
sick they have to be removed in November
Spencer Williams says Trump can no
longer hide behind his rallies he must
now act in the light
I urge him to fire foul Chi so his fans
in denial can see him decapitate himself
I don't know about that strategy I don't
know about that strategy Wes smoke sends
a super chat soul says I believe Joe
would do a better job defending and
fighting for women's rights and liberty
than Trump for those reasons I will be
voting Joe I've got a big piece on
tomorrow's show about Bernie endorsing
Joe Biden I don't have much to say about
it now but tomorrow I'll be talking a
lot about that the hets
says Newsom AOC is a winning 2020 for
unity ticket I don't think she'll be old
enough in 2024 Gavin Newsom is an
interesting guy though for sure the
village idiot says David who's
responsible for your hilarious
thumbnails and titles they crack me up
all over the time so I do the titles and
our employee staffer Noah Ferguson does
the thumbnails ouchie is here so is
Burke's minuchin I believe that's
Admiral pelagic let me say thank you to
Tammy vicek who is new patron number 44
today Kevin Perry is new patron number
45 today David Jones is new patron
number 46 today I'll keep the bar moving
during the press briefing if we get to
50 maybe we'll even be able to go
further but I'll keep an eye on folks
who are pledging and make sure that the
that blue bar above my head stays up to
speed
look
like we're about to start remember if
you're watching on YouTube please hit
that subscribe button and the like
button I anticipate a lot of bragging
today many many lies discussion of the
council to reopen America I do believe
I'm going to be muting Mike Pence that
has been heavily requested by people
Trump will sometimes break news so we
unfortunately have to listen to Trump we
want to hear the questions but pence
provides no value whatsoever so I I do
not believe I think I'm gonna be muting
pence and will be over on c-span because
I believe that c-span is the most likely
to show us the reporters as they ask
questions and I always I prefer to see
the reporters here we go before I begin
I'd like to offer my condolences and
best wishes to the people all across our
great south who have endured deadly
tornadoes and other severe weather in
Texas Louisiana Mississippi Alabama
Florida Georgia Tennessee and South
Carolina
my administration will do everything
possible to help those communities get
back on their feet we're speaking with
the governors and representatives FEMA
is already on its way and they got there
as soon as we heard the word I said get
out there so FEMA is there and you know
you know the great job that FEMA does
it's really something very special so we
just want to say warmest condolences and
and we're with you all the way it's a
tough deal I was a bad bed level-5 that
was a bad group that's as high as it
gets it's a bad grouping of tornadoes
something that's something incredible
the power the horrible destructive power
America is continuing to make critical
progress in our war against the virus
over the weekend the number of daily new
infections remained flat nationwide flat
hospitalizations are slowing in hotspots
like New York New Jersey Michigan and
Louisiana this is clear evidence that
our aggressive strategy to combat
virus is working and that Americans are
following the guidelines it's been
incredible what they've done you looked
at the charts and the charts are and the
models from early on predictions where
one hundred and one hundred and twenty
thousand people looked like if they did
well they were going to unfortunately
perish and we're gonna be hopefully way
way below that number so that will be a
sign of people doing things right but
it's still just a horrible thing all
over the world 184 countries this is all
a tribute to our wonderful health care
advisors and experts who have been with
us right from the beginning we
appreciate it so much in fact doctor
foul cheese here maybe I could ask Tony
to say a few words before we go anything
here thank you a sign to say
everything's great with pouchy it seems
it seems deliberate president just they
won a couple of things and then I would
just want to make a comment about
something that happened yesterday you're
gonna hear from dr. Burke soon about the
numbers that we've been talking about
how things are starting to balance off
and I think the more as we go by each
day I think we're gonna see then again I
never like to get ahead of myself or of
dr. Burke's
but it looks like even though we've had
a really bad week last week remember
when I was speaking to you before I was
saying this was really a bad week
there's still gonna be a lot of deaths
but we're starting to see in some areas
now that kind of flattening particularly
in a place that was a hot spot like New
York that's the first thing the second
thing is that I had a really very very
productive conversation with the
Congressional Black Caucus this morning
for about an hour and they really wanted
to know what exactly are we gonna be
doing and the immediate as a well is the
long range about the health disparities
and the discrepancies both in infection
and in poor outcome in the minorities in
general but specifically African
American and I mean I made it very clear
to them that what we have to do is focus
on getting the resources where the
vulnerable
to be able to get testing done to be
able to get the appropriate
identification wear a proper and we're
appropriate to isolate and contact trace
if we can but also to help mitigate in a
community that is is suffering and
suffering much more disproportionately
so I just wanted to get better the way
the other point I wanted to make is that
I I had an interview yesterday that I
was asked a hypothetical question oh and
hypothetic sometimes can get you into
some told them you got to fix this Tony
would have okay now he's gonna do nature
of the hypothetical question was if in
fact Wow we had mitigated earlier good
lives have been saved and the answer to
my question was as I always do and I'm
doing right now perfectly honestly say
yes Wow if you mitigation helps I've
been up here many times telling you that
mitigation works
so if mitigation works and you
instigated and and you initiate it
earlier you will probably have saved
more lives
if you initiated it later you've
probably would have lost Wow Trumpy
hoarsely initiate it at a certain time
that was taken as a way that maybe
somehow something was at fault here so
let me tell you from my experience and I
can only speak for my own experience
this is unreal is that we have been
talking before any meetings that we had
about the pros and the cons the
effectiveness or not of strong
mitigations so discussions were going on
mostly among the medical people about
what that would mean the first and only
time that dr. Burks and I went in and
formally made a recommendation to the
president to actually have a quote shut
down in the sense of not really shut
down but to really have strong
mitigation we discussed it obviously
there would be concern by some that in
fact that might have some negative
consequences nonetheless the president
listened to the recommendation and went
to the mitigation the next second time
that I went with dr. Burks into the
president and said 15 days are not
enough we need to go 30 days obviously
there were people who had a problem with
that because of the potential secondary
effects nonetheless
heeeeelp at that time the president went
with the health recommendations and we
extended it another 30 days so I could
only tell you what I know and what my
recommendations were but clearly as
happens all the time
there were interpretations of that
response to a hypothetical question all
that I just thought it would be been not
very nice for me to clarify because this
is yeah you thought it would you know I
to be honest with you I don't even
remember what the date was but I can
just tell you the first and only time
Wyman has said we should do mitigation
strongly the response was yes we'll do
it no the travel restriction is separate
that was whether or not we wanted to go
into a mitigation stage it's already an
age of litigation next stuff the travel
was another recommendation when we went
in and said we probably should be doing
that and the answer was yes and then
another time was we should do it with
Europe and the answer was yes and the
next time we should do it with the UK
and the answer was yes that was the
wrong choice of words so we'll discuss
not necessarily in front of the
treasurer people discuss they say well
you know this is gonna have maybe a
harmful effect on this or on that so it
was a poor choice of words that we
should do that work everything I do is
voluntarily please don't even imply that
there was that and if you look at
statistics I happen to write a couple of
them down Wow statistics so this is 1900
in January 6 that's long before the
dates you're talking about
there were CDC issued a travel notice
for Wuhan China a notice before there
was even a confirmed case of the virus
in the United States that's on January 6
there's all documented because we have
so much fake news I like to document
things January 6th
long before the dates we're talking
about CDC issued travel notice to Wuhan
for Wuhan on January 11th we have zero
cases in the United States zero we don't
have any cases so there are no cases
reported that we know if this is January
began to the CDC issued a level one
travel notice health for health while
there was still no confirmed cases so we
had zero cases people want me to act I'm
supposed to close down the economy the
greatest economy in the history of the
world and we don't have one case
confirmed in the United States that's
January 11th On January 17th the CDC
began implementing Public Health entry
screenings at three major US airports
that received the greatest volume of
passengers for how on at my instructions
there was not a single case of the
corona virus in the United States so on
January 17th there wasn't a case in the
fake news to say oh he didn't act fast
enough well you remember what happened
because when I did act I was criticized
by Nancy Pelosi oh my golly Joe Biden I
was criticized by every but in fact I
was called the xenophobic it's just
propagating Biden - please define that
for me
I was called other things by Democrats
and some others not too many others
actually so that by the media definitely
now on January 21st is long before the
time we're talking cuz we're totally
talking about the end of February on
January 21st
okay still early there was one case of
the virus at that time we called it the
Wuhan virus right
Wuhan there was one case in the whole
United States we have one case this is
all documented it all comes from you a
lot of it comes from you people on
January 21st the CDC activated an
emergency operation center there was
just one case one person that's what the
day were it went full dystopian
propaganda now that they think they've
turned the corner they're going into we
have been the best all along nobody can
criticize us it's instead of being 90%
propaganda it's now 100 percent just
economy in the history of the world shut
it down we have one case seven cases
were on January 31st now in January 21st
there was a case not one person had died
you heard that Steve right not one
person so we have this massive country
the United States of America we have the
greatest economy in the world bigger
than China's by a lot right because of
what we've done over the last three and
a half years prior to the virus but
including the virus so we have the
biggest economy the greatest economy
we've ever had the highest employment
numbers the best employment numbers best
unemployment numbers also the best of
everything so on January 31st think of
it not one person has died not one
nobody died not one John you I don't
think you'll find any this is reported
by CDC confirmed by the news which
doesn't mean anything to me because they
don't tell the truth but CDC reporters
bunny how many were the news is all fake
but he cites the news to make his points
issued a travel restriction from China
think of it sighing so nobody died and I
issued you can't get earlier than that
so we have nobody died and I said China
you can't come in I'm sorry because I
saw what was going on wasn't so much
what I was told
it was that I saw what was going on and
I didn't like it
but I didn't speak to Tony about didn't
speak to very many people about it I
didn't like it so what did I do
ready January 31st in the United States
not one person had died because of the
again the Wuhan virus so I issued travel
restrictions and that date even though
nobody died and I got brutalized over it
by the press because I was way too early
I shouldn't have done it
brutalized by the press but you know
sort of I'd been brutalized for the last
four years I used to do well before I
decided run for politics but Ronny I
guess I'm doing okay because to the best
of my knowledge I'm the president of the
United States despite the things that
are said so then first mandatory
quarantine in more than 50 years we did
first million story in 50 years the same
restrictions that the Democrats and the
media called xenophobic now Joe Biden
said he's a racist call me a racist
because I said what is this guy talking
about I know we're shutting it down
he called me xenophobic and he called me
a racist and other things since then on
a Friday night two weeks ago Joe Biden
issued say it wasn't him he didn't write
it I'm sure he doesn't even know that it
was issued but the people from his
campaign who was smart people that write
there's little PR releases a pretty
smart reasonably good nothing best but
they're not bad but they issued a
statement saying that Joe Biden agrees
that the president that President Trump
was right to close it down to China now
he did that and when you shoot it on a
Friday night we've all heard about that
John Friday nights right in fact his was
later Friday night than I ever released
mine on Friday nights okay so he did he
did it pretty late I mean you know like
11 o'clock in the evening or something
you know it's pretty late anyway so Joe
Biden issued and it's one of those
things but in February Nancy Pelosi said
we should come to China tab this is late
February come to Chinatown we think it's
very safe come here let's say I'll have
the big parade
town parade probably referring to San
Francisco how's he doing and that's it
but I took this action early and so the
story in the New York Times is a total
fake it's a fake newspaper and they
write fake stories and someday hopefully
in five years when I'm not here those
papers are all going out of business
because nobody's gonna want to read but
now they like them because they wrote
about me
now with that I have a couple of
interesting we have a few clips that
we're just gonna put up we could turn
the lights a little bit lower I think
you'll find them interesting they're
doing then we'll show answer some
questions I'll ask you some questions
because you're so guilty but forget it
but most importantly we're going to get
back on to the reason we're here which
is the success we're having okay anyone
ever concerned about the corona virus
because they're hearing a lot of news
about it right now but the reality is
comparing it to the flu for example it's
not even close to being at that stage
what if it is worse is this a moment
where maybe countries put politics aside
a little bit of pride aside and do we
have US officials should US
professionals such as yourself get
involved how worried should Americans be
about coronavirus Florida virus is not
gonna cause a major is the United States
Oh God
from pointing oh my god we can ask them
to accelerate whatever they're doing in
terms of a vaccine we won't be
suspending oil travel from Europe to the
United States to unleash the full power
of the federal government in this effort
today I am officially declaring a
national emergency Medicare patients can
now visit any doctor by phone or video
conference at no additional cost the
first 1 million masks will be available
immediately
it's agitprop as there were more cases
and it was clear that it was spreading
out of China where it originated from
pointed on his hand in the bottle it was
widely criticized for by Democrats and
even some Republicans at the time which
was he halted a number of flights from
China into the US the idea was to halt
the spread of the disease look at he he
was accused of an audio he was accused
of making a racist move at the end of
the day it was probably effective
because it did actually take a pretty
aggressive measure against the spread of
the virus look at look at Trump's face
he was on it they've been responsive
late at night early in the morning and
they've thus far been doing everything
that they can do and I want to say thank
you and I want to say that I appreciate
it he returns calls he reaches out
he's been proactive we got that mercy
ship down here in Los Angeles that was
directly because he sent it down here
2,000 medical units came to the state of
California these FMS these these field
medical stations and that's been very
very helpful the president has been
outstanding through all this the vice
president's been outstanding members of
the coronavirus task force very
responsive we get asked if we could have
New Jersey could have access to a piece
of the beds that are on the US and
discomfort and the president came back
called the shorten few minutes before I
walked in here to say indeed they would
grant that to New Jersey so that's a big
step for us in addition to all the other
capacity wreaths that news is literally
hot off the press and I thank the
president and vice president who were on
the call together
president Trump approved Arizona's
requests for a presidential major
disaster declaration I want to thank the
president for a quick turnaround we
requested this on a Wednesday and we had
approval by Saturday morning and we are
grateful to the administration for their
continued support and responsiveness
well first of all I want to thank the
president the vice president for doing a
really good job of communicating with
all the governor okay so we could give
you hundreds of clips like that from
governors including Democratic or
Democrat as I call them governors which
is actually the correct term we could
give you hundreds of clips just like
this can't be held this can't be real we
didn't want this to go on too long but I
just want to say it's you know it's very
sad when people write false stories like
in that case I guess it was gotten
mostly from the New York Times which is
a highly I mean if you had libel laws
they would have been out of business
even before they'll end up going out of
business we have no laws did never win
because it's not like it's too bad but
we could have given you saw the
statements we have hundreds of
statements hundreds of statements
including from Democrats and Democrat
governors and if you look they were all
saying we need ventilators we need you
know here ventilators anymore they have
all the ventilators they need which we
were right about we said you're asking
for too many you don't need that and in
all fairness these two people right here
dr. Burke's doctor foul Chee they said I
don't think they need that many
ventilators I said I agree at one point
and I'm not doc in New York for this but
they're asking you remember 40,000
ventilators and that's more than they
have all over the country and we got
them
lot of ventilators and nobody's
complained we get them as you know
beautiful we built hospital rooms all
over the country the governor of
Louisiana John bel Edwards was very nice
he said you know what you don't have to
build the second hospital because good
news is happening they're not able to
fill the beds they needed two hospitals
we built one it was perfect we're
getting--we're the second one I don't
think you're gonna need it he said let
me get back he got back we didn't need
it with Governor Cuomo in all good
spirit and faith he wanted to have the
Jacob Javits Center done and we built
2900 incredible beds incredible then we
make it we made it covet and or to be
exactly accurate kovat 19 and which was
a lot of work we had to change the
networks and areas we had to put areas
of rooftop things over the beds we did a
lot of work for it I rightfully he
called he said would it be possible to
get more medical help so now not only
are we building facilities were they're
asking us for help because they're
unable to man it and we got him to help
we got Merida Blasio a lot of hell am I
saying when the Japanese I wasn't used
my way and then as you know the mercy we
took the mercy and we took the comfort
and we made them both Los Angeles and
New York we made them kovat adaptable
which was not easy to do and we didn't
get almost any people sent there they
didn't need him at the beginning because
they didn't need it for anything but
this because there are fewer accidents
we were motorcycles here or anything and
what we did was like an incredible job
but there were a viewer every turned out
they were there who we were ready I you
know the expression they have an
expression ready willing and able we
were ready willing and able but the Army
Corps of Engineers did was a miracle
what what FEMA did was a miracle
the doctors did so I got a call two days
ago from the mayor of New York he said
could you help us even more with medical
personnel and we sent and he was 448
doctors nurses and respiratory experts
real experts and I got a call from the
mayor and he said I want to tell you
incredible these people are incredible
he said they lifted the spirits of the
hospital workers from New York City like
nothing I've ever seen he C was
unbelievable what he said was really
appreciated and I let them know that I
let the military people he said they
went in there so brave so incredible
they lifted the spirits of everybody we
did all of this work but when you read
the phony stories you know buddy nobody
acknowledges this and it doesn't have to
be acknowledged from my standpoint but
it does have to be acknowledged from the
great work that these doctors nurses the
Army Corps of Engineers Fame all these
people they've done this incredible job
when does the briefing and they
shouldn't be abused because you take a
look at what's happened nobody's asking
for ventilators except outside of our
country outside of our country they're
calling me every country they're calling
me so many countries there are governors
who never got the ventilators they asked
for until eight is being built but
nobody's asking for ventilators nobody's
asking for beds because we built
hospitals I think we built 20,000 beds
in a period of a couple of weeks the job
they've done is incredible with all of
that being said I'm getting along very
well with the governors and if I
wouldn't Mike Pence had a call today
with the governors and it was like a ten
I said how was it he said it's 210 he is
one of my expressions actually but he
said it was like attend and I'm sure you
people were probably on the Kolo that
you weren't supposed to be but you were
sitting in somebody's office listening
to it because every time we have these
and you know and you would know that for
weeks those calls have been very good
but there wasn't a raised voice there
wasn't even a statement of like we think
you should do this or that I heard it
was like a just a perfect phone call
perfect it might not be reported that
way they'll say I thought that somebody
maybe slightly raised didn't even raise
the voice my only my only point is send
this because I want to get back to why
we're here
yeah wondering ourselves the press has
not treated these incredible people
who've done such a great job they
haven't treated unfairly they're way off
we were way ahead of schedule and
remember this because the time sir was a
fake but everything
remember this everything we did I was
criticized because I was too early after
life if I waited longer it would have
been better if I went way early if I
went three months earlier I would have
been criticized you know criticized for
being way too early so with all of that
being said we understand it I think I've
educated a lot of people as to the press
and I would love to be able to say that
we have a very honest press honestly
John there'd be nothing I would be more
proud of if the press from work and I
don't mind being criticized but not when
they're wrong he minds not when people
have been frittering up yes I've never
seen a video like that plan in this room
it looks a bit like a campaign ad right
who produced that video that was done by
a group in the office and it was done
just by we just put some clips together
I could give you I'll bet you I have
over a hundred more clips they were just
pieced together over two hours I've
produced here in the White House yeah
this was done by Dan and a group of
people and they just put it together in
a pea reporter this is essentially a
campaign video and using White House
staff to produce it I think you guys
know where the reporters going they're
saying what a great job we're doing and
the mita these are the governors of
California Governor of New Jersey
governor of New York look in New York we
work very close with Andrew in New York
ventilators were gonna be a problem we
didn't they didn't have a problem we got
them tremendous numbers of thousands but
we got them tremendous number of
ventilate you don't hear a ventilator
their problem question was about the
babies we're gonna be a problem I mean
I'm happy about it the Javits Center
which is incredible is almost empty
because it was about good news not bad
news I've you know I'm not saying gee I
wish more people were there I don't want
more people there we brought in the boat
we brought in the comfort and the
comfort was originally not supposed to
be for this at all
we went virus they're not supposed to be
for that at all they called they said
could we have it that was a number of
weeks ago we said we don't think you
need it but if you need it we'll do it
then they said could you get the medical
personnel to run the Javits Center
question was about the video did you get
the medical personnel to run the ship we
said if it's necessary we will and we
did we there were military personnel
that's the ones that mayor de Blasio was
so great to in terms of his statements I
mean I really appreciated his statements
he was so impressed with them and I am
to the level of genius and bravery
they're great people the military people
and we pieced that together I would say
it took less than two hours who is done
interesting this is my government
employee by people here at the White
House this campaign-style
all they did was took some clips and
they just read order if there wasn't
they did just to keep you honest no I
don't think that's gonna work it's not
gonna have any impact yeah the video
intentionally a campaign finance let's
you heard what I said
they said I acted late on closing down
the country some people wish we never
closed it thousands of people you know
interestingly so I'm against it we did
the right to everything we did was right
yeah question was if we would have
closed down its long away here you think
everything you did was right well look
governor should have had ventilators
they chose not to have them if we were
able to get a ventilators you haven't
heard other than you know there was a
lot of panic a lot of scream will you
want ventilator
they got the ventilators you know they
said this is actual malignant mental
illness and delusions I mean it's
weaponized it's completely weaponized I
hope you guys realize it okay we have
people standing with those ventilators
right now if you needed 2,000 in New
York which you don't but if you did we
can have them here in less than 24 hours
we're ready to rock this was a great
this was a great military and beyond
that operation let's get back to the
regular we shouldn't we get back to the
regular we could talk about this but all
I'm doing is this I could have given you
like those are four or five clips that
we just play for you I could have given
you hundred
of people I mean Gavin was on television
two days ago with one of your
competitors they haven't even started at
the briefing you know the question was
asked in a negative way he said look I
know what you want to say but what we
have said but he's been really good it's
hard for me to say that in fact it's
impossible for me to say gavin newsom
the governor of california oh oh god I
have many clips from many I have some
clips from Anthony that I didn't want to
put up which were really good I think
Anthony would be the first one to say
when I closed the country to China when
I closed the China ban
whatever you want to call it Anthony
said I saved a lot of lives by doing
that I mean am I correct I don't want to
put words in Anthony's mouth by the way
and I like him today I walk in I hear
I'm gonna fire him I'm not firing I
think he's a wonderful fired somebody no
they said far doesn't know I was thought
about that I said I'm not firing
effective you ask your friends in the
office and the public relations office
no she doesn't have any premedia Lee
called upon that and I said no I like
him I think he's terrific because this
was a person's view not everybody's
happy with Anthony not everybody's happy
with everybody but I will do another
thing with him well you get a job the
likes of which nobody has ever done the
mobilization getting of equipment all of
the things we've done nobody's ever done
a job like this we have 50 governors and
territories by the way people don't ever
mention that we have territories we have
nobody new owners and territories and
many of those governors are Democrats
this is a maniac guys he has to be
removed in November he had this is a
maniac him didn't do their jobs I'll let
you know someday let's see what happens
but I make let you know who's not doing
their job I can tell you the ones that
are good both Republican and Democrat
and the ones who don't know what they're
doing but we help some of the ones that
don't know what they're doing they
should have
had their own stockpiles and now if they
want we can build them stockpiles of
ventilators the hardest thing as a
ventilator because it's expensive it
takes a while to get we got him and
nobody believed we did now many of the
governor's were asking for far too many
and we said they were asking for far too
many we talked and we said you said very
strongly that they just don't need them
and you said they don't need that many
beds Debra so that's it
Steve good you're on the same page
yeah well you have paid for the
beginning I don't know what it is
exactly but if I put somebody's opinion
up you don't I don't mind controversy I
think controversy is a good thing not a
bad thing but I want it to be honest
controversy now when I got a call I got
a call not very quickly and nobody you
know saw that as being any big deal they
said how are you doing what doctor fatty
I said I'm doing great and I didn't talk
to doctor foul even or until we just got
here doctor foul she asked one of the
people if he could get up and speak and
he did and they totally misinterpreted
him I saw what they did he said the
question was hypothetical but what he
was just acknowledging is that lives
would have been saved if the mitigation
practices were putting
earlier that seems obvious do you not
agree with that yes as I know what he
really is saying though but how could
you know he said it look I just went
over stats with you right here right
here oh boy how do you have no deaths
and no cases on January 11th doctor
would you recommend closing the United
States of America oh this must be
terrible how many cases do we have none
how many deaths do we have none
January 17th go back another week on
January 17th this is ten days before I
did the little bit less than 10 days
before I did the ban
I did a ban on China you think that was
easy I did a ban on Europe and a lot of
people said that was an incredible thing
to do because you look at Spain and by
the way we're doing very well because
when you look at all of those flat
graphs and you add it all up the United
States is very low and per capita were
very low we're doing very well but how
do you close up the United States of
America so on January 6 no deaths when
january leavens know this and note no
cases on January 17th no cases no cases
no deaths I'm supposed to close up the
United States of America when I have no
cases the middle of March should you
close the famine I close down from China
excuse me I closed it down from China
coming in for dead by the way some
people think I should have waited longer
and maybe written it out I disagree with
them okay but it was thought up I mean
that was an alternative you know there
are a lot of people that would have said
let's write it out now I'll give you the
good news if I would have done that it
would have been the only good has this
you might be removed and no because
their numbers are anthing 1.6 to 2.2
million people would have died if we
tried to do that and I did this last
time cut it in half I've never seen say
22 million cut it in more than half say
a million people died well that's much
more than the Civil War cut it in half
take the million and cut it in half
that's I'm stealing this different some
people would have right now that number
we would have reached okay that would
have been easy to reach if we did
nothing so we did the right thing and
our timing was
very good but here's the one thing and
you have to say this when you ask me why
didn't you do this how come when I did
the ban on China and some very very
instituted some very tough things
how come Nancy Pelosi a month later is
in Chinatown saying let's all March this
is not going to happen
how come we have many of the experts
from CNN and many other networks if you
call CNN a network I don't personally
but we have seen we have many other
places and they're all saying he doesn't
need to do it he doesn't need to do it
all I'm saying is this how do you close
down the greatest economy in the history
of the world when on January 17th
you have no cases and no death went on
Jesse well I hear is January 20 we got
the case and then he still didn't do it
he's picking the 17th for very specific
reasons so in January 31st I instituted
the ban which took ten days to go into
action went crazy he said you don't need
the ban you he didn't go crazy like he
does he didn't even know what the hell
the ban was but he so he didn't go crazy
but he did say he did call me Xenophon
in a minute he called me xenophobic he
called me a racist because he has since
apologized and he said I did the right
thing so when you say why didn't you
this every Democrat thought I made a
mistake when I did it I saved tens of
thousands maybe hundreds of thousands of
lives by Ibaka
argument is that you bought yourself
some time you didn't
to prepare hospitals you didn't use it
to ramp up testing right so you so
disgraceful it's so disgraceful the way
you said it should be ashamed of herself
I just went over it nobody thought we
should do it and what I did it what do
you do when you have no case in a whole
United States when you excuse me you
reported it zero cases zero deaths for
hours that followed that on January 30
and in fact we'll give you a list what
we did in fact part of it was up there
we did a lot look what did he do you
know you're a fake you know that your
whole network the way you cover it is
fake and most of it not all of you but
the people of wise to you that's why you
have a lower lower approval rating than
you've ever had before Thomson faculty
and rehire pressroom and when you ask me
that question
let me ask you this why did invitin why
didn't why did Biden apologize why did
he write a letter of apology care oh
that's very important to know why did
the Democrats think that I acted too
quickly you know why because they really
thought that I acted too quickly we have
done a great job now I could have I
could have kept it open and I could have
done what some countries are doing
they're getting beat up pretty badly I
could have kept it open I thought of
keeping it open because nobody's ever
heard of closing down a country let
alone the United States of America but
if I would have done that we would have
had hundreds of thousands of people that
would right now be dead we've done this
right and we really we really have done
this right the problem is the press
right doesn't cover it the way it should
be going one more question Steve
what authority you have to order the
country reopen what authority do you
well I have the ultimate authority but
we're gonna get into that in a minute
we're going to just finish this up we're
gonna tell you about other things that
we've done right but I will say this had
we said let's just keep going and let's
not do it closing whether it's 2.2 that
they at one point predicted as an
outside or one point six at a lower
number you cut it all the way down to
six or seven or eight hundred thousand
take just a fraction of the number that
could have happened it literally would
have been more than the civil war it
would have been a disaster
so the minimum number was a hundred
thousand and I think I feel pretty good
that we're gonna be substantially below
Anthony the hundred thousand and I hope
we will alright so today the Department
of Health and Human Service is
announcing five new contracts to procure
large numbers of additional ventilators
under the defense production Act which
we used a lot by the way which you
didn't like to talk about in addition to
the 1,300 we received today we received
at a 1,300 additional ventilators now
we're probably not going to need them
but we can add that to our stockpile
which is very big and we can move it
around should the surge take place and
should it be a very substantial surge
we're ready to were ready to rock
the contracts are with General Electric
Hill ROM Medtronic rest med and VY air
combined with the DPA contracts that we
announced last week with General Motors
and Phillips and two other contracts
with Hamilton and Zoll we're adding six
thousand one hundred and ninety
ventilators to the strategic national
stockpile of which we have a lot already
thousands close to ten thousand but this
will be added by May 8th another 29,000
by the end of May and more than 120,000
total we will have by the end of the
year now we're going to help other
countries we're going to help States if
they need it we may help some states
stop by you know they're supposed to buy
their own stockpile they have state
stockpiles is supposed to be using that
and unfortunately most of the states
weren't there and a lot of people didn't
want to talk about it but everybody's
bought the Trump's we will talk about it
the right
if you want to I at this point I'm more
focused on getting past this nightmare
of the epidemic or a pandemic anything
you want to call it we get you're just
joining us
Trump has spent 45 minutes playing
propaganda videos and attacking most of
the reporters in the room as being fakes
while claiming he did everything
perfectly after forcing Anthony foul me
to say in what is reminiscent of a
hostage I they're treating me well video
that everything is fine and Trump did
everything well I have never seen
anything like this if Obama ever did
five minutes of this people would have
been calling for his head quite
literally we built over 20,000 beds in
fact we built thousands more than we've
actually needed to be safe we want to
thank the patreon really they rose to
this incredible occasion I mean we built
more beds than we thought we thought in
Louisiana we were going heavy and again
when I call the governor I said maybe we
shouldn't build that second Hospital
because we don't want to build it if you
don't need it he called back he said I
don't think we're gonna need it
they had a thousand rooms a thousand
beds and they used a lot of them but
they didn't need the other one so we
stopped it because we don't want to
waste but we're prepared to build
thousands more should we need it I don't
think we're gonna need it because it
looks like we're plateauing and maybe
even in many cases coming down in
addition we've ordered a total of 60
mobile decontamination contamination
systems so the decontamination system
from Patil in Ohio is an incredible
thing because it takes the masks and up
to 20 times you can decontaminate a mask
and I've been asking from the beginning
why can't we sterilize and sanitize
these masks its medical indicator that
we can second thing on great company in
Ohio they sent us some great equipment
and they're doing that now and now we're
going to have more than 33 million n95
masks per week will be cleaned
decontaminated and it'll be great it's
something that frankly I think people
should have thought of a long time ago
five whites landed today as part of the
project air bridge our massive airless
lift operation to bring
personal protective equipment into the
United States which is now delivered
nearly half a million n95 masks 370
million gloves 25 million surgical masks
and four-point point nine million gowns
so we have millions of gowns gloves
masks all surgical equipment coming in
should the states need it now the say
that the states are supposed to be
buying their own stuff but should they
need it we are ready to give up not if
you're building up our stockpile again
like crazy remember I am I and you saw
the stories I inherited this
administration mic myself the whole
administration oh yeah we inherited a
shelter where the cupboards were bare
the covered rug there was nothing and I
say it and I'll say it again just like
we didn't have ammunition we didn't have
medical supplies lyov ventilators we
didn't have a lot of things that should
have been had and you can read your own
stories on that because you know what
happened they didn't want to spend the
money but we did today and facilitated
the supply of more than thirty eight
million n95 masks nationwide this week
we'll be sending two million n95 masks
to the Commonwealth of Pennsylvania the
Vice President will go into more detail
he's got great detail on that and I
think it's will be pretty amazing we
have a lot of masks already in stock and
we have more coming we're further
expanding hospital surge capacity in key
areas of the opening and we have a
portion of certain VA hospitals and
non-veteran coronavirus patients
including at the East Orange New Jersey
Medical Center as well as facilities in
Manhattan in Brooklyn
they're ready they're able they're
beautiful hopefully we won't need too
many of them because frankly we built
everything that the governor's wanted
and in many cases it's too much we told
them it was too much but we wanted to
err on the side of caution early United
States has now conducted nearly three
million tests for the virus three
million the most of any nation not per
capita performing approximately 115,000
tests every single day and our rate of
testing is especially high in areas
hardest hit by the virus
if you look and that's really and it's
hit some areas the virus very very hard
for example per capita testing in New
York is higher than the rest of the
world the NIH CDC and FDA are also
currently validating several antibody
tests that will allow us to determine
whether someone has already had the
virus and potentially become immune to
infection we're looking at that the
antibody tests are gonna be very
interesting over the next short while a
lot of things are being developed as we
speak
in the race to develop effective
treatments the drug company Gilead
announced that its drug remedy severe
has shown promising results very
promising in compassionate use settings
what happened to chloroquine the FDA is
just granted emergency you thought for a
tree moved certain proteins from the
bloodstream possibly preventing a
patient's immune system from
overreacting to the virus and damaging
vital organs which is a playground stone
furthermore over the last seven days my
administration has deployed roughly 28
million doses of hydroxy chloroquine
from our national stockpile we have
millions of doses that we bought and
many people are using it all over the
country and just recently a friend of
mine told me he got better because of
the use of that that drug some studies
are not working well combine it with
z-pak you combine it with zinc depending
on your doctor's recommendation and
having some very good results I'll tell
you think of anybody recommended at
other than me will be used all over the
place to be honest with you I think the
fact that I recommend it and I properly
set it back a lot lie but it's a lot of
good things are happening with it a lot
of good tests scientists are also
pursuing a blood therapy known as
convalescent plasma convalescent plasma
this therapy uses antibodies from the
blood of recovered patients to treat
those who are sick and this is something
that actually is a very old procedure
but it's done in a very modern way
during this difficult time we're also
working to ensure that the 2020 census
is completed safely and accurate
we may be asking for an extension
because obviously they can't be doing
very much right now they wouldn't be
allowed to do it so the census we're
gonna be asking for a a delay a major
delay I think how can you very simply be
knocking on doors for a long period of
time now the Census Bureau recently made
the decision to temporary suspend its
field operation data collection
activities to help stop the spread in
addition while millions of Americans
continue to complete their questionnaire
online the Census Bureau says Congress
for a 120 extension I don't know that
even have to ask them this is called an
act of God this is called a a situation
that has to be they have to give and I
think 120 days isn't nearly enough my
administration is also taking bold
action to help American workers on
Friday Americans began receiving the
cash payments authorized by a historic
two trillion dollar relief bill by the
end of the week nearly 80 million
Americans will receive a total of 147
billion dollars and from what the
secretary of the Treasury tells me
that's very much fun time and going very
nicely he'll be speaking in a moment in
payments these payments go directly into
the banks and the bank accounts of these
people millions of additional payments
will follow the typical family of four
will receive three thousand four hundred
dollars that's for a family of four
that's something additionally through
our paycheck protection program which is
a tremendous success and they should
extend it and increase it this has been
a tremendous success so successful that
the banks should take it a little bit
longer to distribute the money but it's
going rapidly we've now processed over
two hundred billion dollars in loans to
help small businesses retain their
workers now we urgently need lawmakers
to set aside the partisan agendas and to
replenish this program with new funds
because it's really something that has
been an incredible success yeah we can
survive it sure more money to keep it
going to take care of these business and
keep a note them open I want to thank
the many governor's health professional
scientists and business leaders for
their incredible hard work and input
over the past month and even long beyond
a month my
I would say you know we've been working
together with a lot of them for seems
like forever I've been having many
discussions with my team and top experts
sends me we're very close to completing
a plan to open our country hopefully
even ahead of schedule and that's so
important
we will soon finalize new and very
important guidelines to give governor's
the information they need to start
safely opening their states my
administration's plan and corresponding
guidelines will give the American people
the confidence they need to begin
returning to normal life that's what we
want we want to have our country open we
want to return to normal life our
country is going to be open and it's
going to be successfully opened and
we'll be explaining over a very short
number of days exactly what is going to
be we've also as you probably heard
developed a committee we're actually
calling at a number of committees with
the most prominent people in the country
the most successful people in the
various fields that we'll be announcing
them tomorrow
this weekend the United States also
helped facilitate an unprecedented
agreement among the 23 nations of OPEC
plus that's OPEC plus additional energy
producing nations representing many of
the world's largest oil-producing
countries to stabilize all markets and
we have in fact and I think you've seen
a big stabilization over the last couple
of days together countries around the
world will cut our oil production by
approximately 20 million barrels people
are saying ten million but we think that
the number that they'll actually hit is
going to be closer to 20 million barrels
a day and that will help a lot with
saving jobs all over Texas and Oklahoma
and North Dakota and many of other other
of our big energy states this historic
action will help nearly 11 million
American workers who are supported by
the US oil and gas industry it's a very
monumental agreement I want to thank
Saudi Arabia and the king of Saudi
Arabia at Crown Prince of Saudi Arabia
both I want to thank President Putin of
Russia and I want to thank
a very good friend of mine man who's
become a friend of mine the President of
Mexico showed great flexibility
President Lopez Obrador
he showed great flexibility feels good
about getting that one correct and
tremendous intelligence doing what he
did it was not that easy for him and I
want to thank Mexico and the president
this is a very historic deal very
historic so we'll see how it all goes in
this time and challenge and we are
certainly in a time probably like we
haven't been in many many decades we are
strengthened and sustained by the bonds
of love and loyalty that unites all
Americans I'm so proud of the American
people everywhere you look you see the
patriotism of our people shining through
and the courage of our doctors and
nurses on the front lines in the
dedication of our food supply workers
and in the commitment of every citizen
to achieving victory over the virus this
is what's going to happen it's gonna
happen sooner than people think and
we're gonna be smart about it very very
smart about it we're gonna be safe about
it we're going to be listening also to
the great doctors and medical
professionals together we're beating
back the invisible enemy and we're
paving the way for great resurgence
really a great resurgence for American
prosperity our country wants to go back
they want to go back to work they're
going to go back safely and that's what
we want I'd like now to ask vice
president pence to say a few words
followed by dr. Fauci and dr. Burks I
think before we before we do this
because I know there's an emergency
where they want Steve to come so what
I'll do is I'll ask Steve to come up
secretary of the Treasury you can talk a
little bit and then maybe take a couple
of questions about what's happening
tell them the success we're having thank
you very much
some type of middle president mr. vice
president as you announced we are very
pleased that we are ahead of schedule on
delivering the economic impact payments
these were will is known as the checks
in the mail that we want to deliver and
direct direct deposit this is ahead of
schedule we started processing those
last Friday we expect that over 80
million hardworking Americans will get
the direct deposit by this Wednesday and
we know how important that is to all of
those hardworking Americans many of
which are at home not working at the
moment if you do not receive them by
Wednesday on Wednesday we will be
launching at irs.gov click on irs.gov go
to get your payment if you filed a tax
return in 2018 and 19 or 19 have that
information available you'll be able to
ID yourself you'll be able to put in
your direct deposit information and
within several days we will
automatically deposit the money into
your account we want to do as much of
this electronically as we can it's very
important in this day and age it's more
secure and you don't have to go to the
bank if you were a social security
beneficiary you do not need to do
anything you will get a direct deposit
if you have not filed and did not need
to file a 2,000 or 18 and 19 return you
can go to irs.gov now and enter your
information and authenticate yourself so
again we are very pleased that that is
ahead of schedule I'd also like to
announce the progress we're making on
the new SBA program the PPP let me just
remind everybody this is a brand new
program that is now one week old we have
distributed and confirmed 230 billion of
loans to over 4600 lenders participating
that is multiples in multiples of
anything that the SBA has ever done and
in one year before and I especially want
to thank the broad-based community banks
that are participating again over
4,600 banks if you haven't tagged your
loan processed you will get a process
this week as the president said we've
gone back to Congress and ask them for
more money to make sure that every
business has access to this
let me also comment for the states we
are distributing out half the money this
week to the states that's a week ahead
of time and we'll deliver the other half
of the money to the states next week and
then let me just finally comment we've
been very working very closely with the
Federal Reserve last week we announced
expanded facilities and new facilities
that total 2.3 trillion dollars of
liquidity and in particular I just like
to highlight a Main Street lending
facility that will be for companies
between one worker and 10,000 people
so mid-sized businesses and also a
municipal facility for states and local
governments to be able to access funds
given the shortages that they have so
with that I'm happy to answer any
questions to seizures secretary thank
you sir
both speaker Pelosi and Minority Leader
Schumer have said that they're in
negotiations with you right now on
additional funding for these small
business loans that package
leader McConnell Loeb has said that
nothing should be added to the package
that should just be specific to small
business loans but what is the opinion
of your administration should there be
some sort of horse trading here or
should it just be small business for the
president's view and the vice
president's in my view is this was a
bipartisan program this SBA program it
wasn't a Republican program it wasn't a
Democrat program was a bipartisan
program we've committed to small
businesses we should top up that program
now I know the Democrats want to talk
about more money for hospitals and
states right now we're just sending the
money out to the hospitals and states
they haven't come close to using that
money and I know the President and
vice-presidents have said once we get
the SBA done we can go into another
funding bill the president's talked
about potentially adding infrastructure
and other things we think there is a
likelihood we will need more money and
we will we will sit down and try to get
a bipartisan bill but this is important
we deliver on small businesses 50% of
the people work for small businesses
Heiser what's the emergency that the
president said you had to go for you had
an emergency negotiation over this bill
yeah well because we don't want to run
out of money we've used again of the 350
billion we don't want to run out of that
money we don't want to create panics
that people won't get it so that's what
was confusing emergency I don't know
what you're talking about I have an
emergency billion for that program and
again let me just remind you every
dollar we spend in this program we save
a dollar of unemployment insurance so
even though we're asking for 250 billion
it really won't cost that much
you're good you have concerns about
lifting the guidelines too soon what's
the economic impact I understand the
economic argument for getting people
back to work obviously but what's the
economic risk of lifting them too early
and seeing a spike in cases well first
there's economic risks in both
directions we reviewed with the
president today a very broad list of
over a hundred business people that are
gonna help advise the President on what
needs to be done to reopen the economy
we want to make sure and again the
combination of economic impact payments
small business payments enhanced
unemployment insurance the president
made very clear we want to make sure
that hardworking Americans have
liquidity while we wait to reopen the
government so do you believe the
government should be a tree of oriented
country excuse me it should be reopened
on Baine one I've had discussions with
the president I know he's considering it
and I believe he's gonna make a decision
later and the way everything has to be
safe
my advice is as soon as it's ready to
open and based upon the medical
professionals and and again we're
working very closely with the president
and outside business leaders everything
to get my new tune the economy looks
like do you think it's gonna be
everything open what do you figure in
there over the next two days because
we'll probably be making a statement
about that and exactly what it looks
like I know what that looks like but I
also want to get the advice in a sense
we have some of the the biggest from
every business on this council we're
actually setting up a number of
different councils or committees I guess
you could call them and we have a lot of
smart people I think that they will give
us some also good advice but no we want
to be very very safe at the same time we
got to get our country open do you think
there is a possibility then that what
you do is you open incrementally do you
think people go back to rest rose
cultures the cinema and if they sell
eventually they will
they do that and I think we're going to
boom I think we're going to I think it's
gonna go quickly our people want to get
back to work and like a rocket pent-up
demand like that hasn't been in a long
time
well that's why and that's why you see
the stock market I mean to think that
the stock markets at the level it is
right now with all that this world and
this country has gone and look at the
European Union how badly decimated
they've been look at other countries
look at China by the way I've seen the
numbers look at China look at how these
countries have been just decimated by
this and to think that the stock market
is at this tremendously high number not
that much you know was looking a little
bleak for a while but it hit a certain
point and then started going up I think
that's a great tribute to the fact that
there's a demand yeah mr. president
thank you sir all right gives regards to
some of your tweets earlier today and I
think it was Steve's question my
question to you is what provision in the
Constitution gives the president the
power to open or close state economies
and then numbers provisions will give
you a will be looking forward to that
sir output following up what happens if
you say for instance we want States to
reopen but California or New York
do not open what would you do ordered
schools closed it's been states that
have word businesses like restaurants
because I like that happen because I
would have preferred that I let that
happen but if I wanted to I could have
closed what a sweaty liar this guy like
the way they've done it and the seven
that remained really in sort of a semi
lockdown if you look at those states
they've really done a very good job
they're very much different from in New
York or from other places where they've
been hit very much
small I order you to open your schools i
order you to Fidel yes mr. president
following up on that there are two
consortiums of states today California
Oregon Washington on the west coast
northeastern states
totally representing about a hundred
million people who said they're going to
cooperate and decide wind real they can
just trigger but what you're trying
downtown at all let me just a very
simple I'm gonna put it very simply the
President of the United States has the
authority to do what the president has
the authority to do which is very
powerful the President of the United
States not going to laws the shots if we
weren't here for the states you would
have had a problem in this country like
you've never seen before we were here to
back them up we're back and we've more
than back them up we did gonna be a
fight nobody ever thought was possible
it said we're gonna work with the states
because it's very important you have
local governments they're pinpointed
it's really you talk about it's a like a
microchip they're pinpointed we have a
local government like that hopefully
will do a good job and if they don't do
a good job I'd step in so fast but no
they can't do anything without the
approval of the President refused to
reopen and you order them to the Tenth
Amendment of the Constitution says all
powers that don't resign the president
resigned in the States how do you well
if some states to refuse to open I would
be I would like to see that person run
for election something that's not gonna
happen they want to open to have to hunt
they have you get open every one of
those states that people want to go and
they want to now some will be earned a
different situation you have I won't
name states now but I will over the next
two or three days I'm gonna be very
specific but you have some states where
this is not the kind of a problem than
it is in New York or Louisiana or
Michigan or other places that got hit
very hard Illinois got hit very hard but
all states want to open and they want to
open as soon as possible but they want
to open safely and so do I yep
today the French president in menu and
my corn sentence here we keep the
shutdown in France in the middle of May
does that mean that the US will keep the
banner French got hit very hard France
got hit very hard and again he has to do
what he has to do is friend of mine
didn't even listen to the quacks Spain
has just been decimated question was
well what's happened in Italy it's a
very well known fact what happened in
Italy no they were hit very hard
question for secretary Venetian does
anybody notice that the question was
will you keep the flight ban until that
same time he didn't answer now we've run
to a different question now that we just
reviewed the names but the president
today sectors yes there's basically
there's vertical so every single area of
the economy we wanted to be represented
great one other thing is there anything
else needs to be done to to work on
industry oil industry jobs to save oil
industry jobs after the deal this past
weekend well I think there's always
things so we're working with Larry
Kudlow
I mean we we have the green lands for
every single part of the economy
obviously in the case of the oil
industry they've been hit especially
hard because you've had both the the
supply issue and you've had the demand
issue it's the big announcement bailout
money for the airlines with the
allocations for the airline so I'm
pleased to say we've worked very hard I
think as you probably have seen we put
out a press release that we have now had
discussions with almost all the airlines
I've personally had discussions with all
the major airline CEOs we specifically
created an exception for small airlines
that we could process very quickly and I
think you'll see very quickly decisions
coming out I'm very pleased with the
discussions we've had very good
see I just want to say we have had
discussion wait excuse me one second
we've had very good discussions with the
airlines very good discussions possible
to reopen the economy on made the first
I don't want to say you'll be hearing
over the next few days push in lieu of
another stimulus so again let me just
comment I mean Congress on a bipartisan
basis approved an unprecedented amount
of money to help American workers in
American business because it was no
fault of their own that business was
closed down we we have been very
diligently executing on that you know
everybody said it was gonna take months
to get people money we are executing
very quickly we created a whole new SBA
program in a week our job right now is
to execute the 2.3 billion which we can
add several trillion dollars with the
Fed the one area we are particularly
concerned about is the small business
program quite frankly it's even more
incredibly popular and successful than
we anticipated so the president wants to
be very clear we have money for that and
once we get done with that we will
review it the president if there is more
money that needs to be to support this
economy to support hardworking Americans
we will work with Congress to get that
done phase four so phase four the
president has has talked about
infrastructure for a long period of time
we've talked about to the extent that
the hospitals need more money because of
the medical issues will will monitor
that we want to make sure there are
incentives for restaurants entertainment
people to get back to those types of
things so we'll be looking at very
specifically provisions to stimulate
parts of the economy some of them may be
money issues some of them may be
regulatory issues
just to clarify your understanding of
your authority these are the governor's
just be very specific for instance if a
governor issued a stay at home when you
say my authority the president's
authority right mind because it's not me
this is when somebody's the president of
the United States the authority is total
and that's so it's got to be total
excuse me excuse me the question you
have a couple of bands of Democrat
governors but they will agree to it they
will agree to her but the authority of
the President of the United States
having to do with the subject we're
talking about his total we saw in your
video about was the trouble ban from
Europe it's part of reopening America do
you want to reopen the borders so
there's people from Europe from the UK
at the right time very good question
actually well I'm gonna have to take a
look I wouldn't say Italy is doing great
right now and I wouldn't say Spain's
doing great right now and we just heard
that France is extending its stay inside
order right they say they've extended it
I just see that and I think for a short
period of time but no when they're back
we want to do it very quickly but we
want to make sure everything's good no
right now we have a very right now we
have a very strong band we're going to
keep it that way until they heal weeks
months what would you I can tell you
that I have to see how are they doing I
mean France just went for another two
days for another two weeks we have to
say John she said that you took his
advice on the question of mitt
he made the recommendation you accepted
Annie put it in place as you make this
next decision which was I'm sure that
John I'm not sure who really gave me
advice on the band I think I took I
think I took my own advice okay with
that all the social distancing I'm
talking about the shutting down okay not
a travel don't open up but of activity
so my question is does you make this
next decision which you have said maybe
the most difficult or important decision
of your presidency will you assure the
American people that you will again take
the advice of the doctors of doctor
kouchi of dr. Burks will you take the
advice of the health experts before you
do and many other people also but I will
absolutely take a take would you help
against their recommendation if they say
you need another 15 or three I don't
think it would be likely because I think
we're not very far from being on the
same page please yes mr. president one
thing that Governor Cuomo is said today
is that states do not have the capacity
to do mass cope in nineteen testing
ahead of a reopening and they have to do
look you're supposed to be because the
diagnostic tests or equipment and needs
federal health so will they need help
but well but they're there they're on
ground they've got local mayor's so just
so people know and you're not gonna miss
anything important here different road
maps to reopening say that to really be
able to reopen much at all you need as
few as a million tests a day and as many
as 22 million tests a day 22 million
tests a day would let you test the
entire US population on a rolling 14 day
period that's it
we're just it seems like a non-starter
maybe we could get to a million tests a
day we're at about a hundred and twenty
five hundred and fifty thousand right
now they have such a great test as that
in fact what I'll do I think unless you
have any further questions for the
secretary of the Treasury do you have
anybody for see if anybody is exhibits
for me we can wait we go
for secretary mination a question from
one of my colleagues is not able to be
in the room they're curious about the
SBA rule that prevents small casinos
from getting some of this relief is that
something that you're taking a look at
if they're going to be exchanged not
small casinos but there are such things
as small taverns and restaurants that
have literally you know small gaming
things and and we are coming out with
some additional guidance on that but I
want to be clear it's not small casinos
secretary knows there was a letter that
some House Republicans sent this weekend
about liquidity for mortgage servicers
yes sorry can you explain what you're
looking at on that front sure so I think
I commented on this a week or so ago we
had a subcommittee task force at F sock
that specifically studied this issue we
have all the appropriate people on it
Ginnie Mae has automatically taken some
action we've had conversations with the
FHFA as to what they're gonna do for
Fannie and Freddie and we've said that
to the extent they need certain
authorities from the Treasury we will
accommodate that so we're we're very
aware of the issue quite frankly we've
been studying this issue way before
kovat and had concerns about some of
these non-bank servicers not being well
capitalized but we're gonna we're gonna
make sure that the market functions
properly
thank you sir we have seen in a number
of these relief bills that Democrats and
Republicans have been able to push
forward different non rotavirus specific
funding priorities are you trying to
keep funding specific to coronavirus and
then if there are going to be other
additions for instance a change to labor
rules is something that many on the Left
when it some on the right are wondering
if they should also if you should also
be pushing for you know their preferred
add-ons
I think our expectation has always been
this is kovat related some people have a
rather broad view of what kovat related
is because it has impacted almost every
single business I mean I think we've the
president has talked about the Kennedy
Center which is a good institution
obviously that was not the major
priority the bill but they were hit with
kovat related so but know the president
has instructed we want to be very
specific in the next bill
it's kovat related items just so you
understand that was done the Democrats
wanted it in we didn't want that but
they wanted it in and we had some
clarity something done for the workers
but we want this to be for the workers
and for companies that employ the
workers that's what we're looking for
we're not looking for extraneous
nonsense what you argue that at the time
of the [ __ ] was being discussed that
that was too disruptive to the global
economy
I had nothing to do with the Shina ban I
wasn't on the task force at the time I'm
not even sure I was I think I was
traveling at the time but I never had
any I was not part I I did become very
active and after the China ban but that
report in the New York Times was not
accurate before I was not hard with the
task force at that time and I was and I
was not involved
matter of fact I think I may have been
traveling by Senator Holly to get direct
payments to employers to pay people who
have been laid off and people on payroll
that is the PPP the PPP is basically
sending money to small business fifty
percent of American workers to keep
those people paid and it's the most
efficient way every dollar as I said we
do through that it's one less dollar of
unemployment and more importantly we
want those people to have be associated
with the business so as soon as the
president is ready to open up the
economy those businesses are together we
don't want those businesses to fall
apart that's why this is such a
successful program but he was truly
offended about the unemployment sending
it in directly to the states we would
have preferred that it was sent directly
to the people the Democrats wanted it to
be sent through the unemployment system
and you know I've talked to you about it
we have 40 year old equipment in many of
those systems that run by the state but
I'm hearing they're getting the money
out anyway so some some of them are and
some of the states aren't and we
encourage you know we're working with
the states to try to update their
computers but it's a long haul
phase four Steve phase four come on
Steven you just said you said when
someone is president of the United
States their authority is total that is
not true okay you know we're going to
write up papers on this it's not going
to be necessary because the governors
need us one way or the other because
ultimately it comes with a federal
government that being said we're getting
along very well with the governors and I
feel very certain that there won't be a
problem yeah please go ahead has any
governor agreed that you have the
authority to decide when their state I
haven't asked anybody because you know
why because I don't have to go ahead
enough please oh the vice president's
called to talk governor Hogan of
Maryland has urged your administration
to ask Congress for 500 billion to help
stabilize budgetary shortfalls created
by Governor Hogan very much we
appreciate going ah it's not the
question
KOMO said the cares act ignored stink up
warming shortfalls do you see that
request mr. boilers
he said the cares Act ignored the
budgetary shortfalls
well they're looking at things in phase
four where they have you know where they
talk about states and they're also
talking about hospitals they're talking
about states who have been battered and
they're also talking about hospitals
that were certainly willing to look at
that Congress will see what we all come
back with but they are talking about
states and they're talking about
hospitals non-essential goods she had
banned the sale of non-essential Goods
many are calling this draconian no she
as president
do you think that if other states were
to follow her example in the coming
weeks I don't think that's gonna happen
I think it's very extreme but my thought
is garbage question my thought is that
they're not showing a close-up of her
because she's not supposed to be in the
room like I think there is a concerted
effort by everybody who follows the
rules that I mean they shouldn't even
put the camera the wide shot I think
they should just pretend she's not even
there we're gonna be talking about that
very soon of getting a full report I'm
not happy with the World Health
Organization not happy with the World
Trade Organization either we've been
ripped off by everybody and we have this
country for so many years
has been ripped off by everybody whether
it's a world health or world trade and
they're like I call them the Bobbsey
Twins they look at our country for years
and years we had people that did nothing
about it we're doing a lot about it so
we'll have a report and we'll also we're
also talking about the World Trade
Organization but we've made a lot of
progress there we're now winning cases
for the first time because they know
I'll leave if we don't get treated
fairly this country our country was at a
point where we've rarely if ever won the
lawsuits with in the World Trade
Organization but now we're winning a lot
of them because they know I'm not I'm
not playing games we will pull out if we
have to we just won a seven billion
dollar lawsuit which was very nice
decision this week on cutting funding
for the yeah I would say by the end of
the week I'm gonna make a decision on
that you know there's a lot of right now
there's a lot of things happening China
why are there no consequences for China
for the misinformation no there's no
consequences why would I tell you
concerned that they still know you
started off by saying why are there no
consequences you're gonna find out I
wouldn't tell you you'd probably be the
last person on earth I'd tell what mr.
vice president do you agree with the
president's statement and his
understanding of federalism that his
power is total under way describe
everything it's Lamar add or in context
you'd like to ask me from weight was
discussing that I I support the
president's leadership under the
national emergency declaration that he
signed we're standing before you today
at the first time in American history
when all 50 states have issued emergency
declarations and the territories this is
an unprecedented time in the life of the
nation and fortunately as presidents
reflected and our health experts will
continue to reflect because the American
people have heeded the president so I am
gonna mute pence I made a commitment to
do it he's not gonna talk about
federalism so this obviously trump is
wrong and Trump doesn't have the legal
backing on this if he tells New York to
open there is nothing that will that
that allows him to force Andrew Cuomo to
tell schools in Brooklyn to open right I
mean that's a decision for the mayor of
New York City and for Andrew Cuomo he's
totally wrong they'll come up with
something they'll figure out something
that they can use to say well generally
speaking there is some authority here
but it's it's completely and totally
laughable it's not going to happen we'll
we'll see now if they go back to two to
trump or if Pence is going to continue
talking
and as the president said will happily
brief that but in the days ahead what
the president has charged us to do oh
now he goes again but let me take this
opportunity to thank the 58 people that
have pledged on patreon I really
appreciate it tomorrow on the show we'll
have updates on reports about what is
the real case rate what could we believe
the real case rate to be we'll talk
about Bernie endorsing Biden and Noam
Chomsky saying you've got a vote Biden
over Trump we'll talk about that
we'll talk about this new pandemic
council to reopen America two sevenths
of the council is Trump's own family
another two people are people who
thought coronavirus would be great for
the economy so four sevenths at minimum
is made up of completely incompetent or
nepo ties to people I think that that
may may be a term that I just invented
also thanks to everybody who's been
sending super chats I am seeing them
they will continue to pop up on the
screen while Mike Pence
blathers and blathers and blathers and
this is truly an unprecedented time and
the neat the big news from today is it
sounds like in the next few days Trump
will outline the stages of reopening and
that'll be very very interesting to see
look at the European Union as a whole oh
my god they have nearly three times the
mortality rate that the United States of
America has today and that is a tribute
to our extraordinary health care workers
yeah I mean the truth is you've got to
act you know if you take Italy and Spain
out of it the death rate in the European
Union is actually far lower so the you
know the value of saying something like
that I don't know that it really tells
us that much about the quality and
access that's happening here in the
United States not overwhelmed with this
hour and and I have to tell you standing
here today I I couldn't be more proud to
stand alongside this president and to be
a part of this team that has served the
American people during this
challenging our and I I've just say to
you to every American looking on as we
see the numbers leveling and maybe even
beginning to go down I just encourage
you to keep doing what you're doing
because of the sacrifices that Americans
and American families have made through
these mitigation efforts you're saving
lives and you're seeing our nation
through this disease tell you you've
been talking to the governor's quite a
bit did those coalition's of states on
the west coast and up northeast did they
tell you what they were going to be
announcing before they announced it as
governor Phil Murphy and the governor
Connecticut expressed today that they
were going to be speaking on a and
discussing on a regional basis what
their recommendations would be and and
we assured them today we show them today
on our conference call with I think 48
governors that were with us today for
the better part of of an hour and a half
we told them that what the president
would be producing as directed to be
produced or additional guidelines for
the state's certified by the CDC that
would inform those governors and local
communities and mayor's about the best
way forward based on the unique
circumstances that those states and
those communities are facing I think
what's clear is the American people have
seen the experience in Washington state
where this really all began for us and
in California and now the extraordinary
challenges in the Greater New York City
area including New Jersey and
Connecticut the challenges in New
Orleans and Louisiana and Detroit still
Chicago parts of Houston but they're
also seeing that in each one of those
cases that the mitigation efforts are
truly working and so we'll we'll work
with those we'll work with those states
and in some cases it'll make perfect
sense for them to work together
but the president the president will be
I'm sorry I didn't hear you a question
you didn't hear it three times he didn't
look at that disgusting face on this
guy's face expression on his face three
times she asked did they tell you ahead
of time
always governor's is I think every
American would be proud to see the
partnership that this president has
forged with governors across the country
I mean it is an extraordinary statement
and you'll see some data when Admiral
pull object gets up in just a few
moments but the flow of resources from
around the world that we've moved into
areas that have faced challenges I mean
this president has directed us to ensure
that every state has what they need when
they need it and the spirit that I heard
again from Republicans and Democrat
governors today was reflective of that
partnership and as we move forward to
the president's goal of reopening
America we expect the same kind of
partnership in the interest of the
nation you can hear me through the mask
early
the District of Columbia argues that
they was shortchanged in the most recent
funding bill because they were treated
as a territory instead of his estate
will that be made right in phase four
well we're looking at that certainly I
heard that complaint but the mayor seems
to be very happy with everything which
she's actually and she was on today
saying very good things okay yeah go
ahead in the back yes mr. president you
talked about this being the most
difficult decision that you are going to
have to take about whether to reopen the
economy I wonder how much it weighs on
your mind the thought that if there is a
second way you've reopened the economy
and you might have to shut things down
again it does and I hope that won't
happen
I certainly hope that won't happen but
it does weigh on my mind okay in the
back go ahead
thank you a question for one of my
colleagues who wasn't able to be here
China deployed an aircraft carrier into
the South China Sea except China see
this weekend amid claims by chinese
state media that kovat has reduced US
military readiness readiness in the
region what kind of responses are you
thinking of will you have a response to
this action China has their own
difficulties we have a relationship with
China that we're not happy with certain
things that happened over the last
period of time as you know and I've been
very explicit on that but we know all
about that and know China's we've seen
what they did we've seen many other
things that they've done both pro and
con and we'll be just fine here where
you've said they don't bring together
the the economic task force and then you
thought that the recommendations were
happening earlier than expected did you
mean to suggest that it could be before
May 1st that you start recommending I
don't want to say but we're gonna be
putting our guidelines and
recommendations fairly quickly in a few
days before but look certain states are
doing very well certain big parts of the
country are doing very well they're
doing really very well so we're gonna be
putting out recommendations and
guidelines very soon Steve your
guidelines be
where they fit each area or they'd be in
a uniform you see I don't want to tell
you now but right now we have a very
strong indication that we know pretty
much we have some good ideas I also do
want to get I want to have we'll have
video conference or at least the
conference call with a lot of very good
people having to do with certain fields
whether its energy or whether it's
entertainment and restaurants etc
etcetera we have to get people back into
restaurants we have to do what we have
to do whether it's deductibility or not
we'll see but it should be deductibility
you'll get them back so fast I mean they
used to have deductibility the
restaurant business it was one of the
hot businesses and then they ended it a
long time ago many years ago but we may
need that to get people back into the
restaurants please yeah today million
voting nationwide as the possible
solutions in the States
she said it shouldn't be a partisan
issue have your advisors told you that
the state lives
well absentee ballot are you talking
about massive scale because of the blow
I don't know what she did I mean I
didn't see that when did that happen
today your phone calls yesterday with
President Putin the Kremlin is saying
that you discussed current issues of
ensuring strategic security that wasn't
referred to in the White House readout
can you enlighten us many things we did
discuss China we discussed many
different things but we was primarily a
call on the oil as you can imagine and
they were very helpful in getting a
stabilization price stabilization of the
number of barrels I think the numbers
going to be closer to 20 maybe 15 but
closer to 20 than it is going to be to
10 and I think it was a very important
call I also spoke with the king of Saudi
Arabia and that was a very important
call and the bottom line is OPEC plus
it's gotta balance because there are
other states also other nations we came
to a very good agreement please
so what was the part about strategic
security was that dumb I would say
mostly we were talking about China we
were talking about their borders and we
were talking about our borders a little
bit our borders with Mexico because as
you know Mexico was a big part of the
deal and Mexico
exactly very complex from the standpoint
ago Porto was not an easy deal for
Mexico and the president we appreciated
a certain amount of flexibility but we
talked about borders we talked about
China talk about Mexico well I mean I we
did talk about the arms oh yes we did
that was a very important part of it
yeah good point
please Abbott Labs you said testing is
going great we know that they have these
machines have been sent to some of the
governor
some of them are saying they don't have
the materials actually ended up well
they have to get the material you know
the governor's have to get the material
now if they can't get it they're gonna
see us talking about the local
governments I'm talking about governor's
have about the material now there's a
waste wouldn't account I just might to
go into it as soon as I leave they have
very powerful machines that they don't
know they even have I'm not talking
about Abbott I'm talking about the
governor's they have machines that are
used for this you know what I'm talk
you know what I'm referring to it's very
very powerful machines we're in a
certain States case they're only using
10% of their capacity and they didn't
know it that happens to be Illinois John
these 15-minute tests that you sent out
these new ones that you had in the Rose
card
they say including governor Sununu in
New Hampshire that they Don the
cartridges actually conduct the test so
we will they get those cartridges
rapidly increase area rapidly increases
well pretty quickly you have other
machines where they can really work and
a lot of the states have the big
machines that can do a lot they didn't
even know they had him they didn't even
know that they had them and Mike is
gonna be talking about that remember you
mentioned several weeks ago the that
Google was putting together that website
and all the drivers and Apple have you
if you give me humble an apple come
fasting a lot of people don't like it
from the standpoint of constitutional
rights no but what about the Llyod and
some people think it's great know they
are working on that as I understand
they're still looking I'm sorry
and and it's only copper ting and I
think five counties in California right
now looking at it but Google is also it
was a lie dude we have business
companies in the world looking at things
that in a year from now everything that
we're looking at now is going to be
obsolete that's how good it is we have
things happening that are unbelievable I
saw a presentation today there was three
or four weeks ago when Trump announced
that said it would be up within a week
Google was like huh what doing very well
in the vaccines they're working hard on
the vaccines and I think you'll have an
answer for vaccines I believe that
there's some great things coming out
with respect to that now you need a
testing period but you're gonna have
some great things please are doing so
different subjects on the cot I know
this is this is the Google and Apple I
don't know if it's a partnership or what
but they're working on some they're
working on more than one yes they're
working on a couple of different things
Google and Apple Google is also working
on something as you know having to do
with testing I believe they're doing
that in a singular fashion so my
question is not about the drive through
testing website not that but on Google
Apple's contact tracing right they want
to they've got this process now where
they can put
you know contactors have your phone if
you opt in you can be alerted if you've
been this your contact with someone with
recurrent virus do you how do you feel
about well it's an amazing thing but a
lot of people have some very big
constitutional problems with it you know
she knows a lot about it's an amazing
thing and it would be actually as you
know other countries are thinking about
using something similar but not as good
I hear Singapore is Singapore is
Singapore had a little bit of a setback
because they had a they had a break you
know that and but they'll take care of
it I know I know the folks in Singapore
they're doing a great job and they're
gonna put it back for it quickly but
Singapore and other countries are
looking at other things and some
countries are doing other things further
Americans you some I don't want to get
into that because we have a whole
constitutional thing we have more of a
constitutional problem than a mechanical
problem but we will be making a
determination on that that's something
we're going to be discussing with thanks
a lot of people over the next four weeks
that would be a very accurate way of
doing it but a lot of people have a
problem with it yep Lascaux testing
question maybe for dr. Fatih as well can
you talk about vert the antibody test is
in how well it's moving along I think
that kids because I have to leave moving
a little quickly moving along well it's
a test that's been going along for many
many years except now we have very
modern very incredible versions of it
but that's moving on the antibody test
moving along very well okay any more
kovat 19 Kovac 19
status of captain Crozier the performers
well that's going through the Navy as I
understand it the Navy is going to be
making decisions on all of that and they
had a break in I don't think the ship
should have been stopping in Vietnam
when you have a pandemic to be honest
with you you know I don't think the
captain should have been writing letters
he's not Ernest Hemingway as I said
before and he should have been writing
letters and I don't think I don't know
who gave the orders to stop in Vietnam
but they stopped in Vietnam and all of a
sudden they get on and now you have over
500 sailors and and people on the ship
that are affected I don't know whose
idea that was but that wasn't such a
good idea in the middle of a pandemic
yes on this question of
constitutionality I'm just wondering
what changed your view because nothing
changed I know exactly what you're gonna
say nothing change it the fact that I
want to rely on States or maybe will or
maybe have and the fact that we've
gotten that's one thing the fact that I
don't want to use the power is another
thing look look the standpoint of the
Constitution yes because you you thought
should be on stone you can look at
constitutionally you could look at
federalism you can look at it any
different way John the fact that I don't
want to exert my power is much different
we have the power you as does the
federal government have the power
question is from previously said
constitutionally the states have to
decide stuff now he's saying
constitutionally he gets to decide I
would rather stay god I would rather
work with the States because I like
going down to a local government that's
why with I guess it's now seven states
not eight that could South Carolina did
you know they went away from what we
discussed the last time so that's why I
looked at the individual states they're
doing a very good job they're really
doing a very good job I'd rather have
them make the decision now the fact that
I'd rather have that's fine but I have
the absolute right to do if I want to I
may not want to we have a very good
relationship so we'll see what happens
if you notice the few states you're
talking about they're all with Democrat
governors
but if governors are doing a good job
and they control it better because you
don't have somebody in Washington saying
set up a testing
in Deedle parking lot of a Walmart and
we're in Washington and they're in a
state that's very far away that's really
it should be and it should have always
been and I've always said it was the
relationship we have now with the states
and governors is very good and we'll be
announcing over the next very short
period of time exactly what we're gonna
be doing okay couple of other fighters
and Joe Biden he's the presumptive
Democratic nominee do you have any plans
yet on when you'll start sharing or when
the White House will start sharing some
of that information about the corona
virus well nobody's cold about
coronavirus about from their standpoint
well other they have all he had with
Biden about coronavirus last week which
is swine flu and that was a big failure
there was a tremendous failure they had
a lot of failures and you take a look at
what you take a look at the history and
you know 17,000 people died and you talk
about late they were so late they were
late like it never even existed that was
a that was a big problem of course a lot
of other people a big problem too so you
know if Joe Biden would like a briefing
I'd certainly get him a briefing I don't
know what he'd do with it
yeah please vodka I want serving on the
out on the new task force and how are
you gonna pan out what no then
in earlier conversation there was a
description of multiple different
councils or tasks task force's you just
explained exactly which is the White
House Task Force which really brought us
up to this point brilliantly I must say
dealt with governors and dealt with
governors all the way through and and I
was on many of those calls and every
call got better and better and better it
was hostile at the beginning but all the
way up in today's call was a very good
call very friendly call I think
everyone's on line and again you don't
have anybody driving you crazy saying
they're not getting ventilators and not
getting all of the different things they
need more beds they have a lot of beds
right now and we always heard I think
it's supportive you know we always heard
from the sake of giving more remember
there was how many different councils
and task forces are there that they were
asking for we didn't think they needed
the ventilators that they asked for and
we were right now in ventilators we're
ready to March I told you this we're
ready to March we have 10,000
ventilators we're ready to move them
anywhere in the country we need them if
we need them we're also building a lot
of ventilators and that's going to be
used at some point I believe you know
we're gonna have stockpiles including
state stockpiles if they want to work
out some kind of an arrangement with us
but we're also gonna help other
countries whether it's Italy or Spain or
other France is having a big problem
they all desperately need Germany - they
need ventilators so we're gonna have a
lot of ventilates we have a lot you
heard the numbers we have a lot coming
next week next week we have a tremendous
amount coming ok final question
No then we have in addition to that we
have a number of committees
we'll have a transportation committee
we're going to have a manufacturing
committee you'll see it tomorrow we're
also having a religious leaders
committee we have a great group of
religious leaders we're having
committees with religious leaders you've
been seeing what's going on with the
churches and all of that and we're going
to have a faith leaders committee and so
we have we're going to have a few
committees I'll call them committees and
then ultimately we're going to make
decisions so we're going to make
decisions fairly quickly and I think
they're going to need to be the correct
decision I hope so Steve form the
economic test worse tomorrow when do you
want them to have recommendations oon
and they already know what I want and so
what do we form when you say form I
don't have to give them instructions
these are very sophisticated people
these are the best people in their
fields so I'd have to say she let's we
just met and we're gonna meet in two
weeks and here's what what I said here's
what I want we've already told them and
that the the best names in the various
businesses and professions and religions
I mean these are all the best names the
people that I think probably know the
best so we've called them and we're
going to be speaking to a very soon and
we want them to have if it's questions
or statements we want them to have that
for us and we will have either response
or maybe I mean ideally we're gonna be
learning from them and we'll be able to
do that and put them put everything we
learn from those calls into our new
guidelines so we're gonna have new
guidelines coming soon I think it's
going to be very good I think it's going
to be very smooth and I hope it's going
to be very safe thank you all very much
thank you sure
sadly Shara is a friend of mine for a
long time he's a great real estate
person passed away was a great real
estate person great great sort of a
legend in New York real estate he called
me a couple of weeks ago said he's
tested positive
Stanley's in his early to mid eighties I
guess and Stanley went to the hospital
and he never came out he went into a
coma
it was unconscious for a long period of
time and he never made it a great man he
left very charitable really a great
philanthropist a very very successful
person in Manhattan in the real estate
business so I got to know him a lot he
was so excited when his friend from New
York became the President of the United
States he was like like it's all about
from the young boy and he was not a
young boy but he was like a young boy he
was so excited he thought it would do
such a good job and he was so happy and
he he was very proud of what we've done
in this adventure matter but he was
tested positive and unfortunately he
didn't make it
it's a verse to me it's a verse say I
think thank you all very much thank you
president I guess they're gonna continue
for hours I'm at the end of my time
we're three hours in and pence never
says anything of substance so that's
gonna do it for me today thank you for
the 61 people who did make a pledge on
patreon I really appreciate it we will
be back at it tomorrow maybe with some
new guidelines about the process for a
reopening really really an experience I
mean just a crazy deranged harebrained
diabolical press conference thank you
for joining me I guess
you